[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
round 11 of the US and US Women's Chess
Championships here in st. Louis the
tension reached the fever pitch as four
players came into the last day dreaming
of winning a national title
Aviano Caruana kept his hopes alive with
a victory against Alexander onus choked
but it was Sam Shanklin who scored a
dominating win to be crowned u.s.
champion in the biggest accomplishment
of his career team sensation anyway
finally lost her first game of the
tournament to last year's champion
sabina for serve which sets up an
exciting matchup with na z by kids e to
close out and already dramatic event
it's time to decide who will be the
queen of us chess for 2018 rapid
playoffs for all the marbles coming up
next
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
of the 2018 u.s. Chess Championships
held here at the st. Louis chess club
today is the playoff stay and we're
going to see anyone battling Nazi
Pakeezah for the national title who is
going to win it all
only time will tell let's go to the
studio and start today's round yes sir
Jan and Maurice Thank You Christian I'm
Jennifer shadi and I'm here with yasser
Sarah Wan for one more day of US
Championships Luis women's championships
here in st. Louis it's playoff Monday
Jen and let's see what the final
standings of the championship itself was
before we set up today's actually well
Sam Shanklin took down this crown an
astonishing style with a plus six core
and that Nets him the 50k first prize a
prestigious title the Olympic spot and
twenty-seven hundred plus rating for the
first time in his career
a breakthrough career breakthrough
result for his career it was there he is
the man of the hour
that's right congratulations to sam
Shanklin our 2018 us chest penalty
enemies but in the women's championship
we still have chess to be played as any
wagon Aussie PAC is er tied at the top
of the table with eight points and
that's why we're here the playoffs will
start in just a few minutes as it's been
a dramatic and exciting event and
there's still more drama and excitement
to help now they got here in slightly
different ways naazy because he's still
undefeated auntie Wang losing a tough
game and the final round supports this
playoff and here's a format we've got
game 25 it's a two game rapid match with
a five-second delay it back undecided
either by wins for each player or by
three draws then we move to Armageddon
and Armageddon the pitas are determined
by the drawing of the lots white will
get five minutes plus a three second
increment black four minutes with the
increment and if it's a draw as in all
Armageddon's black goes home is the
winner
exactly draw odds for black and look at
this relaxed young Annie wearing always
so cool
it's just a pleasure to see somebody you
know I have such a tough loss today and
then bounce back like this but Maurice
has more on the different roads these
young ladies took to the playoff they
were plant they're facing in each other
today well our two great rivals today
they played marvelous chest much like in
the other section that saw a runaway
first and second place
they have also distinguished themselves
with +5 eight points that normally would
win it all but no we're gonna decide on
a playoffs and just take a look at how
they got here first of all 2016 champ
now see pi kids e she didn't lose a game
in 2015 she didn't lose a game in 2016
when she won she lost a couple last year
but back to her perfect ways not a
single loss as you see there how she
started and then a couple of wins then
some draws that she beat Irina crushed a
very important win and that daring win
she had her back to the wall in a
must-win game in round 10 she was able
to pull it off against Avraham Yan and
now she finds herself playing for it all
well anyway got here in a quite
different way she started off with a win
and then a couple of wins after a draw
and then look at that middle six seven
and eight bang-bang-bang she also
defeated arena crush and then na z pi
kids e that was a tough draw she went
through all the champions go to T on e
crushed by kids he's a ton ski and then
finally against last year's champion she
tripped and lost against voicer but here
she is she still has a chance tied at
the top and we will decide who is indeed
the queen of us chess in just a few
minutes and we're gonna throw it up to
executive director here at the Chess
Club
Tony rich who is going to kick off the
playoffs
welcome to the playing hall as we begin
the playoffs for the 2018 US Women's
Championship I'm joined by our chief
arbiter Ken belieu who will assist us in
the drawing of lots just as a reminder
to the players we'll begin with two
games game in 25 minutes with a
five-second delay there will be a
15-minute break in between games if
that's undecided we'll go on to the
Armageddon portion Armageddon will be
five minutes versus four minutes with a
two-second increment for both sides and
black will have draughts
ken has a black pawn in a white pawn
behind his back
and if our former US Women's Champion
would do us the honors of choosing a
color nasi has chosen the black pawn so
in about five minutes she'll begin with
the black pieces and Annie will begin
with the white pieces thank you both
very much
thank you Tony and once again to
emphasize the increment is a very usual
bonus that you get for each move you
complete in this case of the rapids it's
a five-second delay so your clock
doesn't actually take down until you
until the sixth second has elapsed what
do you think about the colors yes who do
you like to start out in a two game
match with so much at stake do you
prefer to start with white or with black
always with black because it's if you if
you lose the first game you know what
you've got to do if you start out with
white and you make a draw somehow you
feel like you're not on home court
advantage anymore and also if you start
out with white and you play a poor move
that spoils the game and you lose having
to win with the black pieces is a really
big ask it's going to be a challenge for
this youngster here as we see anyone
who's been cool and calm throughout the
tournament she played our worst game off
the entire tournament yesterday she had
such a nice position coming out of the
opening and then that night maneuver
descending her night of straight on the
b4 square only to see it have to go back
to d5 and then she just got mauled by
some being a force that she was never in
the game her vaunted defensive skills
seemed to escape her with all that
tension in the last round one could have
expected that would be very difficult
for her the question is just how tough
is her mental game can she come back and
playing we see nazia Pike is he there
looking very calm she's thrilled to be
in this position she couldn't have
dreamt it which was a point behind that
she would actually chase down the
teenager in the last two rounds and she
was just looking dead to all rights
against etat to have Abraham yawn and
then manage to turn that game completely
around and win so she's got to be
feeling a surge of confidence she knows
how to win this one will Annie
actually break through and taste this
victory as
experience matters in such situations
Annie at 15 years old
facing it for all rights and purposes a
veteran 24 years old but she's been
playing in youth tournaments ever since
she was a youngster so she does have a
lot of experience but does she have
experience in this time control and in
the playoff format we've never seen her
in a playoff in the Women's Championship
the time that she wants you unclear
right and she does play in the Pro chess
league but you don't see a lot of rapid
tournaments in her playing history so
obviously she's the favorite you know
both in terms of momentum the fact that
she's in a good mood getting this
opportunity and her rating but I
wouldn't count anywhere now at all not
at all we're looking forward to do you
think I'm gonna say that maybe 60% in
favor of Nagi but you know in these
situations when we said it very very
well nerves
it's not just about the chess it's
remaining calm and relaxed and playing
within yourself and also another point
as well nasi wants it badly if you look
at her throughout this tournament and
the way she carries herself it feels
like there's just this internal desire
to win this so badly
like she tasted it in 2016 she knows
what it's like it also matters to her
career more and it can lose this and go
back to school go back to doing homework
go back to track you know back to
playing the piano it's not going to be
something that do rails her and affects
her in terms of her personal life that
much this could mean a lot for the Naza
who's really a professional chess player
and as they shake hands about to start
this could be in a lot for in terms of
invitations future invitations with that
title under your belt you're the US
Champion if not you may just be
overlooked as hey you couldn't beat the
kid way but the players are playing
airplane yeah but the plane so very fast
right they've not using the five-second
delay in any way no needs of yet well
you know sometimes you just want to
steady yourself at the very start that
it's all guns blazing c75 on the board
first very sharp move and has caught
given any pause right in this moment
because it begs a question what happens
if I take on c5 if I capture this bond
it's not going to be that easy for black
to recapture I am allowing D 5 D for
attacking the Queen thinking toward I'm
leaning towards Queen g3 but okay
I could also step back I suppose a5 to
round up the pawn I think we G 3 is
probably the most challenging move in
that position might as well test black
right I mean the walls over and she has
taken on c5 the thing is and there it is
d4 on the board the thing is that nasi
we've seen and there's Queen g3
definitely the most testing looking move
in the position but nasi by kid Z well
prepared for it instantly banging down
96 we have seen her play sharp openings
right in these tournaments even a little
bit dubious looking opening but she has
not been fearful and again she has
prepared deeply for this and once it
badly in this position she clearly has
seen at home on the board this is going
to be a real test for an e in the next
few moves exactly and and basically
let's just take a look I'm the old Ponte
grubber amongst us I'm going to grab
this pawn and try to retain at the
moment this pawn as well you can't play
Queen a5 check that would be a mistake
because the knight on f6 is being left
unprotected oops
so you would I'm assuming she's gone for
it she's after my own heart grabbing
those two pawns right out of the opening
and we fine you know she has
Lord this is serious prep this is
absolute preparation Annie has walked
right into it
and look how calm nausea is she has
looked at these variations
she probably prepared this for the
championship itself right and now the
preparation is there and she's just
looking away knowing that she has banged
out these moves this is going to be an
enormous challenge for Annie to be able
to wind her way through these just
really crocodile-infested waters yeah I
think it a very complex of variations
and eastman indeed Marie's and don't
forget this is a time control where the
very well-prepared players is likely to
get a big edge on the clock and and he
she's not stopping either Bishop g5 has
been banged down immediately only move
and Queen h4
again the pace of play is extraordinary
for me and the engines not happy with
Annie's last move the Bishop g5 move and
if Nancy remembers our preparation then
she should be playing h6 pretty much
almost automatically it's another move
Queen a5 check to play in this position
which looks super sharp that move is is
the very strong here as well that
they're settling on as the right way to
play Queen a5 and after Bishop d2
surprisingly Queen a4 is supposed to be
its engines number one she's number one
choice so if na sees in her preparation
she must have looked at there it is she
is totally in it now and we expect
Bishop d2 on the board if she was
waiting for you know full-scale
preparation and to remember everything
she's not even taken aback upon which
looks like the most logical choice in
this position Queen ain't for showing
control over the board and all the black
pieces coming in the game surging into
the game this looks good especially for
a wrapping yes what unbelievable
preparation what development look at
that all the pieces still on the first
rank oh she took the pawn okay Queen
takes e5 on the board it's hard to tell
in Rapid weather sometimes whether it's
preparation or just fast moves that's a
thing because
both players do want to stay ahead on
the clock so maybe the company's last
couple moves 46 Queen a 5 check were
actually not preparation I think I think
it could be because Bishop g5 wasn't
optimal so when you see a when you're
looking at the optimal moves and you say
the other line oh that's not that
serious right I'll just play into that
if she had played the main line that she
analyzed she probably would have listed
out instantly then Bishop g5 comes she
says I don't think that was good because
I have rook g6 and Queen a5 and I'm good
and once she's seen that but it could be
that you didn't refresh your analysis
too much and now she's in a different
position from the the one she expected
as the main main line so now that
they've deviated a little bit it's time
for Annie to start playing chess and
settling down and she did play a good
move you know to eat before preparing to
develop her King side pieces with Bishop
d3 92 note that Bishop d3 does not hang
the pawn on g2 in this particular line
because the rook is defending this
knight on f6 e to e4 essentially you
know whites upon up but that development
normally speaking when you're ahead and
development you want to open the game on
passant would be your move except in
this case this pawn on d4 makes such a
great impression she may not want to
give that pawn up right away and maybe
move like Bishop e6 in the order to
prepare Castle and completing her
development but before yes she's going
to be looking at that and realizing that
this B pawn can chase her Queen
backwards eventually that's going to be
something she wants to analyze a bit as
she's taking on c5 instead of playing
that Queen name for move that's going to
concern her in this position to just
play that Bishop move although of course
as you mentioning it's it's pretty
obvious that this is tremendously
development also I mean maybe not before
immediately because there's also this
eventual idea of rook to g4 thats
hanging over over blacks head over
whites and white said excuse me it's
it's not looking like it's it's our
yield just yet but it's there like it's
a capice right because everything
you're gonna have to move your king it
looks like you because you can't block
with anything because I'll throw a d3
that's you you gotta keep an eye on d3
as well exactly opening line before
there's so many ideas here for nausea
just looks miserable to play for any
weighing in a rapid game yeah this is a
very big challenge indeed and I'm just
not that easy for nan Zi ler because
there's so many tempting possibility she
does have to just choose one exactly so
imagine oh she's such a great practical
player but I could see in a classical
game a team in attack here
I mean actually a rapid game it's not
gonna happen that's it it is a key
moment keep your rhythm keep your rhythm
in a rapid game but then you have to
know exactly when to slow down and start
just playing moves and also annie has to
remember when to ditch upon back yeah
like you're up upon note when you're
time to just throw away that pawn back
so that you can settle the position I'm
thinking I'm Poisson they actually lead
to serious play for black so this is the
current position we've just seen the
movie to e4 we all know that um Poisson
is one of those ways of opening a block
position after check you can't play b2
before this rook on a1 is not
sufficiently protected and I'll take
advantage of the pin to grab the pawn
and threat of night c2 which is
devastating the bishop has to drop back
and then let's say the Queen drops back
to b6 basically urging black-white to
port her King
over on the key whoops I'm about yes I
got it yeah yeah Knight is about to drop
into b3 and the bishop is coming to f5
this looks 94 maybe run out Bishop f5
right away Bishop f5 if you like right
away I mean just what are you what are
you going to do
Queen b3 is coming before anything else
I mean this looks horrible threat of
mate in one and it's horrible so I'm
thinking I'm posada is really very very
dangerous indeed for any you know just I
just
you're moving to the computer and the
computer agrees the engines agreeing
that yes on facade is tough just keeping
the game wide open with that lead in
development it's going to be very hard
to defend and it's only computer s moves
it's starting to look like that's
defending this position and it's still
bad
that's a nice maneuver should should she
recapture with the F pawn doesn't look
that I know it might be the best way to
play it might be just the best way to
play to keep lines closed and Bishop f5
and b4 is being suggested as the top
move here the only way to keep yourself
in the game chase this piece back and
now BB five nobody's going to play like
this that just looks scary right be fun
but maybe b5 is good here because the
knight can't come into the position it
has to back up and you've got although
I'd be ready to suck a piece I'm going
to tell you and actually the engines
giving rook d8
yes rook d8 as a possibility I'm not
sure why but my instincts said not to
move that night and not rook d2 what's
this move about King takes Oh in ninety
four perps is hanging yes so that
they're alive their tactical lines
that's hard to analyze all that though
very quickly that's just a possibility
out of this position and AD as to why it
is that nasi staring at the board right
now
game game position is back here big
decision your one chance to open up the
game what takes on e3 and you have to
see what you get
she's a solid player so she might think
her Trump's with the pawn on d4 outweigh
the opening up of the position but
there's no question she's looking at two
seas there's something forcing down
there or a position that she can
evaluate very quickly and say that's got
to be good for me and say she did not do
it she did not do it she decided to keep
that pawn on d4 and she played instead
Queen D cities are anticipating before
pushing the Queen back and protecting
and I don't have six introducing that
threat of work to do for it yeah we're
talking about you know she was perhaps
looking at despite the fact that it
would hang a knight on a six
okay well I'm really afraid of the move
rook g4
I know possible right I'm just thinking
that my queen after up g4 could find
itself really hunted down f2 f3 protects
the pawn on e4 and then d3 I imagine
what our ideas here is to play d3 try to
get that night in to d4 you think you're
ready to meet it with Bishop c3 and
castles so if I can round up this pawn
on d3 without getting seriously injured
yeah that'll tokay it looks ok but boy
there's a lot about this that my my
spidey sense says you know like this way
way too much compensation here for black
your move is actually very strong move
as is the move h3 f3 though I'll go down
h3 supposed to be superior but I like
your move because it's just so human f3
and the move you've just played d3 the
slightly inhuman but also a logical move
Queen f2 allowing the knight to land on
the d4 square which can then be maybe
play it can be then be met by Bishop to
b4 and suddenly all squares are
defendant Bishop to b4 that you can't
play nine c2 because you'll take it and
if you move the Queen then clip the pawn
on d3 and what are you doing that
actually defends the entire position
that'll be if she could find those two
moves she will have found it pretty
human way actually of just consolidating
so she wouldn't need to first realize
how throwing the thread is on g4 it is
two moves to do that f3
allows the clean and run back and then
if you just run back it looks like white
is just okay Queen b6 was not the most
points and move in the position so the
reason that line works is because so d3
yes um queen up to 19 for Bishop before
with a delayed yet Dina temple was key
because Bishop takes d3 right away
allows a knight B 3 and B 1 does not
save the game because the the Bishop 1
d2 is in the way so that's why you need
to get the bishop because she's
surrounded she's found it if and then
Queen after Queen to d7 you can because
because you move the Queen to b6 but if
you move it back too
seven it's important to how that would
be one move yes sorry let's do that
again just to show what you mean by that
so now Bishop here and instead of the
Queen b6 rej go back to like d7 or da
for instance like 38 now Bishop takes T
3 and now the knight be right because
it's so important yeah be very important
swishing zu let's get to the game
position because I've come up with an
idea for Nagi let's just develop
everybody loves development Bishop e6
challenge for white okay I have it in
mind following an idea that suggests
queen up to protecting the pawn on g2
right let's suggest castles that's the
jest Bishop d3 now what I want to do as
black is open up the game as much as
possible with the move
f7 f5 but my Knights in the way well
let's borrow page from the Benoni let's
maneuver the night the c5 square so that
I can play f5 I think it's time to play
b4 shut it down yeah weird about 95 then
there 5 right now right well the point
is if if I get you to play some move
like this oh whoa then I'm investigating
all kinds of crucial squares in White's
position so I think the move b2 b4 is
necessary right and good ok good is okay
let's say I don't open it up further
I'm not coming in a fight is not coming
I have to tell you even if you put
something behind that and play a 5 I'm
feel like I can take it Oh what if it's
a knight might be different maybe it
might even induce g4 I really really
want to get it by 5 and I'm kind of
eyeballing I don't know kind of a queen
a6 can't take on c4 92 here though no no
82 what are you
gonna play fi for a reason yeah I really
want to get now so d3 was that d3 okay
now now we have to see whether now
there's some regrets that now there's
some serious regrets that I'm passant
well yeah not play yes and that you know
there's another thing too you can
prepare all you want in chess eventually
you'll have to play the game and if you
have a wonderful preparation it gives
you confidence but when when it starts
to go off a bit starts to go awry the
positions not as dominant as you thought
it was you start thinking in the back of
your mind did I forget my preparation
right did I yeah do this the right way
and it can be that because you were so
high from getting your preparation that
you start to the momentum in
psychological momentum starts to shift
downwards dramatically we've all
experienced this right
I remember played again a game against
Viktor Korchnoi and he walks right into
my preparation I was like oh this is
good Viktor the Terrible in my
preparation look at this and that man
sat on the board and worked on some
lines and then started playing some
World Championship cans and it moves on
me and then I started tanking and I said
what is that I didn't know that move
what is it and it just went from great
to equal to bad to push in the toilet
crush me depression
it's your preparation is not enough it's
and you've got to say even if I get a
good preparation I still have to play
the game so preparation only gets me in
a in a good state and that's all and
that's all you get and when it starts to
not be just right that's feeling just
starts to go in you and if Annie starts
to bounce back I got caught in
preparation but hey my position has
looked so bad now then her psychology is
on the rise as well and you won't see it
because she never shows anything on her
face but she'll feels so much better
when she's able to make a few more moves
and she finds Queen I mean it was a
beautiful move that is an incredibly
strong consolidating move and it it's a
little counterintuitive because Annie
knows full well she wants to develop her
pieces oh my goodness she came to play
oh my goodness
after making yeah okay because you as
white you're absolutely anxious to
develop your King sight and to delay and
delay and delay this move Queen f2 as
you were mentioning Maurice it's an
x-ray coverage of the c2 square 94
Bishop b4 protecting the C 2 square and
Nagi will go another pond now that's a
pawn on c4 because if she sees 94 Bishop
before she'll realize that's not the
path to take Bishop e6 still just play
with the fact that weights
underdeveloped absolutely but the
problem for black is that if you if you
don't get your knight in to d4 then you
know how do you flood your pieces into
the position but wait don't wait to play
here what does y do exactly so let's get
this I have to play I mean I don't want
to play c5 and create more weaknesses or
maybe I do yeah you want to lay c5 let's
just have a look c5 the bishop
development was to attack the pawn on e6
c5 rescues the pawn and gains a tempo
the Queen will drop back to d7 and is it
time to see if we can round up this yeah
right or even potentially castles as
well right
I can you can stop work do you on with
Bishop b3 as well exactly I still don't
think this is far from out of the woods
friends over the board this is a very
well played rapid game so far bars with
great we're weakened immune for a lot
more excitement especially if they
continue to burn claw that's the thing
okay so Knight age 3 so I'm still I
still have in my ambitions
maybe queen e3 is actually a look no
just did some quick a quick look at the
engine yeah and there is a very
dangerous moment for for na z because
there's another unusual maneuver in this
position you back up just this 2 here
and 94
plate is already irrelevant but Bishop
e6 this move yes rook c1 to c3 two takes
on d3
that's unusual what a rover parties yes
that was possible just defend your pawn
then go right after that pawn that's
very hard to hold exactly now the whole
game is turned around she's gonna rip
that pawn off on d3 and just be up to
pawns Zak Willis counter-attack Annie
we've seen that throughout these women's
championships you get about it position
sometimes but when you give her a chance
to counter-attack she's right here oh
yes oh boy
that's gonna be just to pause there's no
right this there's some kind of
compensation but it ain't the same like
it was close upon we also can unravel
our king position with 92 so exactly not
just the act of winning the pawn it's
the act of winning the squares around
the pond right black pawn goes and 92 is
instantly follows right behind it and
then suddenly by the way it's two pawns
two bishops ever add great structure
right structure don't normally see much
from naazy because these facial
expressions for right now
she has been right by this move
annie has proven herself an exceptional
defender throughout this entire
championships she has been amazing and
defending she looked lost yesterday in
terms of the lights the import of the
the occasion she couldn't live up to it
and she defended so poorly she was not
herself but she has brought back her
a-game today definitely caught in
preparation but look how she's playing
it wonderfully finding just the right
movie for every f2 boss and the thing is
after he's not even the inches number
one recommendation right you could feel
the humanity of the move hit guard g4
get my coin out of there and she's
played very logically brought the Queen
back and now Ozzy has just walked into
this position and she thought had
momentum and it turns out she's just
losing a second prong well if you don't
see that the Queen on f2 you know x-rays
and guard c2 naazy probably played the
move Knight d4 thinking I got this this
is a bishop before totally twenty-six
played [ __ ] of cakes d3 there goes that
critical critical pawn on d3 that black
spent so much nazis idea here to try to
gain some play no question about it get
those pieces off the back ranked 92
let's go lady - so you're saying that i
want to get rid of the knight on d4 it
doesn't work because Knight takes d4 yes
that's a tempo so that's why I love this
move 92 mm all right developing and it's
not a game it's not a castle right guys
yes and Aziz time situation is bad what
happens on castles I'm getting there's
no discovery that works for that night
you can't buy a pawn on c4 you can't do
anything right well you're shut door
shut right if you take one you two first
and Queen e2 bishop h3 there's a gap -
first there's work f2 at the end oh
thank you yes you're right hold on
because the engine went nuts just a
second ago it's 92 Queen - is there a
tricky three work three and Bishop c4
that might be saying the knight hh5
freddy native where g3 doesn't help
because we have NATO for anyway right
that's bad and Bishop d2 there's like
Queen d7 or some things that she has
played now we're up to date with the
play maybe two castles only only chance
now I guess I should just take this guy
I should just let out take it you'll
take rookie look I'll just Queens like
castles tricks are still in the air for
Annie yes right she gonna play this way
or you're just gonna castle immediately
which is also a natural move you know
taking on d4 and you know being forced
to move your bishop backwards it's not
that intuitive if you think you can just
castle yourself and it also gives up the
sea
I know that is a work see one on the
board in front of you but I was pointing
out that it's kind of you're allowing
these things yes you have to realize
you're allowed to make this happen and
also a big point here yes the rook on d4
doesn't coordinate well with the work on
g6 so you actually want this rook to be
on this core because you can always kick
it out with the gypsy 3 right and
there's a t5 pawn hanging as well so
this this idea Knight takes d4 she's
gonna have to tank just for a little bit
I realized castles is hasty yes if she's
asleep if she just waits just a moment
and says but although can she play can
she fight castles
you play this line let's go back one
second back back back here
castles again immediately yes so we were
doing Knight PC too you could probably
do bishop you know do 92 yeah that's
what I wanted to do too Bishop takes
know what if you take bishop tasty - how
bad is that
not as bad cuz mate h5 doesn't work
anymore
that's an exchange though right - I know
give me this if you give me this
position with my with my dark square
Bishop and two pawns I like I don't mind
giving you a change away in this
position no no no no I do like in the
worst case in the worst case if you
notice it right you do it you said okay
whatever
take that she might be analyzing it
right now and trying to assess whoa
she castled queasy allowing Bishop takes
e4 boss bold as they come Wow because
after this move well well what we were
thinking was that Bishop takes e4 didn't
work when we had to move rook c1 now it
is available but you know what this is a
pretty strong movement you don't have
time to capture with a Discoverer -
check that's right act check because
your Queens under attacks before Bishop
c3 looks strong
I was about to say I should see to just
with the idea of bishops I can't you
also take on c4 yeah he has played but
you takes you four guys okay so what I
want to see this come on 94 d4 Bishop c4
is that is that a bad idea on the board
now c1 me now I'm great but I like
keeping the two is definitely you know
to a little extra king protection the
point is we got you know good players
here arguing about good choices yeah and
she could pick whichever she was she was
exactly let me tell you is boss she's
just showing her daring on the board and
she has her choice now of easy ways to
liquidate down to just being up a pawn
with no issues whatsoever King tucked
away and she has I think I take brownie
points for that would think it may not
be the perfect move but it's definitely
a good move move our King off and guess
whose rookie who's King is on a sea line
and again that g6 rook not coordinating
well and that knight on f6 not that good
either
he sense the danger that the King on g1
would be endangered because it moves
like Knight h5 Knight f4 Bishop h3 and
meanwhile the King on b1 is gonna be
safe as can be exactly time to get on
it's that this knight on f6 2 is being
corralled by the pawns on e4 and f3 all
of the key good squares for the knight
are protected for yes King b1 yes
the a7 part is hanging that means you
have no time to deal with the issue on
the King side you can't move the night
you came with the rook that's all day
because a7 is gonna hang and you can't
allow that to happen so rook d6 is gonna
land on the board also will in fact
correct you're just gonna get blown off
the board in this line you cannot play
rook takes but you have to play Queen
takes absolutely one miserable as well
he takes King moves that looks awful she
has played rook takes and King b1 and
this is a dead loss position they look
equally terrible Maurice because we
can't even play King v8 or faith in them
and then the rook on each wall the rook
is coming this is just a completely lost
and rook d6 is coming Queen a7 I mean
what are the threats for white you
almost have to play Queen b6 here and go
into a terrible ending upon down
[ __ ] resided on Knight d7 okaying
the a7 pawn that the whole point was she
she saw that Queen b6 was a terrible
ending she saw this threat of rook d6 so
she played nighties maybe seven eight
right well I
well Queen a7 I'm guessing that g2 is
what she has a minor check on a 88 I'm
just desperate to play rugby eight oh my
god
rugby I just want to do it yo move it
turns out and so it turns out that this
is the current position - this is the
current position we takes a seven on the
board so rook so Rho G - G - this is a
spike she's played so great and that I
want to just do everything right Bishop
d6 is crushing because your last chance
if you play it is a rook takes check
right is rook takes check King takes yes
that's your only move rook takes well
there's no other move right yeah he's
rook I mean look T and then this check
and then King Bannick gave me one and
then you resigned no way there's no
check done done notice that's it her
last chance and that's not going to cut
it how did this opening go from complete
preparation fantastic for black from
because we said this queen a4 was
devastating then we saw takes 23 why and
then there was a third in accuracy I
like about these laughs if I'm assigning
even d3 once once you see the it's very
difficult to see you in a graphic game
but once you see the queen f2 idea you
can't play d3 you got to do something
else you're just giving up two pawns
then so with the with the position
opening up for the bishops four of
anyway okay boy now move 14 C for 114 E
for Wendy takes III can happen move 14
it is now Queen takes a7 is moved 24 in
the space of 10 moves from efore full
preparation fantastic position ten short
moves later completely winning four-way
right it it has not been that long we're
still in miniature we're in miniature
range 24 moves right sub 20 she has
taken on g2 and that's this is done
allow that's that's it Queen check so if
Queen check is devastating with Bishop
d6 but I also was thinking your your
attempt to hunt down blacks King isn't
so bad either yeah the only thing is
that she has rook rook before after King
d7 I wanted to play rugby one check and
win the game easily but then rugby four
stops me which means I have to play
Queen takes on e5 it looks like and have
that position because of you on a queen
h8 right so I mean Bishop d6 is the most
direct though absolutely what you want
also just getting one also really
striding to get rid of your active right
because on c4 doesn't lose good - that
looks too many good moves so many
because Mairead all she needs to find
and there's another line sorry there's a
knight the back one move King c7 just to
confirm that Bishop d6 is the best move
here no no check he has checked she has
checked and so this move is the only
move my knight back is just lost exactly
I back - you're done but this one
they check on a fox they should check on
85 b6
well I'm thinking can't I check here my
recent kind of drag your King up the
board yeah yeah but where's your king
going if it goes to a 6 yep
okay and now can I bring my rook into
play threatening a checkmate okay I
think Bishop a5 check b6 between 87
check okay let's go back to that moment
where my move Bishop d6 chestplate it is
the only way to play only way to play it
now it must be some physics queen is
black that any work takes me to no no I
finding nothing okay so that's why we
can see seventh running Queen d8 me yes
oh no you know the funny thing is Bishop
e7 was her key move against Irina crash
yes so maybe she'll do it again is that
Queen on f7 that's beautiful that's on
Sakhalin right that's the move Jen we
should be seven that's it that's done
you don't have a move no rook d4
no Amy no there's no move how do you
stop mate you have to play years no you
have to play Knight b8 in LA Bishop d6
at minimum right yeah yeah Bishop d6
resigns right so no there should be
something done find this it's over right
one move one move define the route takes
B to track it is the desperado that we
chose before right rabbit you on and
then go back and when check happens just
go back to b1 and actually you'll be
throwing in checks this is a 50/50
moment
how did the mercury go crazy when you
had your book on b5 I guess was her was
her line I mean not that it really
matters but when you were looking at
something with Murphy five and did that
open up the rook takes B to line again
sorry King c7 which rip d6 was it
looking you say like work t5 here or
something and for some reason it was
just lost and I couldn't figure out why
maybe so trying to find trying to find
things before that's why work takes
before that's okay cuz I was like Rick
b2 still doesn't work but rook takes b4
works she's got to bring the big gun in
she's got multiple moves here and Bishop
e7 is definitely actually a threat
there's a five-year play Bishop a5 year
for a second though that forces b6 right
so now visa clean is hanging right now
what is the material count is five pawns
so this so there's no way you have to
win this position Queen a7 check I don't
know mm-hmm but then you play King c8
right and I just run out of steam in a
big can I take on b6 maybe Brooke c1
computer really why did that why did it
go haywire there Wow I actually thought
rook c1 was a good move boom and so it
must be something like two or something
that one this one and whoops okay
that was really bad okay no Bishop a5
check that that's a step in the wrong
yes yes like Jennifer your moves rope
g1i but she's looking at a lot of moves
the point is which is there a slip here
like Bishop a5 you look at and you
better know that it's not the right way
to play because you're gonna hit a slip
she's also concerned about the rook b2
thing hopefully she's establish that b2
does nothing that's really important to
establish that that is not a threat but
Bishop e7 is a quiet move and that might
make you much harder to find with also
want to play all the chess moves
good yeah no rook do you want an open G
- right that's that's the point you do
actually black actually does have a
threat rook takes before this is why not
if you chosen fine there is like one
tray okay but if I'm just playing a
bullet game and I don't see Bishop e7
yes I definitely see rusty six posting
obviously with a threat of the Queen and
you know following it up with what
doubling the rooks and going after the
night on d7 ya realize that three of us
are talking so once - we're throwing on
different moves and analyze real fast
she's got only one mind in her head and
one brain - look at all these options
exact and she knows there's a win here
you can see she knows but the question
is will she figure it out in time eight
minutes for Annie and seven for Nagi so
they've been keeping pace with one
another well anything this is the
benefit of her great time in relaxing
and calculating they're just fine 87 but
usually mace I love the unusual beta
Bishop e7 and even push the pawn to b5
Bishop e7 and you play something like b5
to defend against the mate because this
mate on that Square and echo and vicious
fighting on the e7 square exactly
championship square even if she wins
this game it's not over there's not a
championship how it's going but she
drops that move on her now and wins this
game is gonna be a big psychological
blow
it's an Ozzy amazing move we were
talking about huge psychological edge
coming into this game and yeah didn't
turn out for her so and certainly in the
opening she had a big eyes she looks so
relaxed and comfortable but you know it
came down to what you were saying as
about even though they had the delay
they were playing completely instantly
right you thought zone in a little bit
take a few seconds per mole exactly but
no this is they just let's doubt that
opening sequence and again guys I've got
to say that rook d6 he's
sucks and now she's gonna go into some
random endgame with Queen takes c6
probably yeah then the rook on g2 is
actually well placed for that ending but
after rook six that's such a hard move
not to play because your own it's it's a
gain of a typo no but the point it's
less yeah it's more of a gain of a tempo
but less of a gain of a temple in check
you're hitting the Queen but you're
still keeping the other pieces on the
board like Queen b5 for example what's
possible this ship this one throws away
the better part of the advantage forces
an endgame position that she can trade
and she doesn't have to go into the
endgame she could play queen 87 in
Bishop c3 and that shuts down all of
life you can't play Queen d7 King c8
Bishop c3 c3 yeah alright and I can't
take because the Queen b5 right let me
talk to going to another stupid endgame
that would be bad news and she has no
why am I talking she's playing my moves
no please no no I realize I could come
back to that rook g1 idea too right now
right now check on the back rank yes
don't be too low route g6 if you do that
no that is true but at least I now when
I play bishops Bishop c3 your Bishop
before there's no meeting by the way I
can always transpose to a pretty good
endgame with rook takes g6 take some g6
work takes d7 Queen d7 and Queen a6 and
I'm gonna be up so many pawns there
aren't I
yeah whoa careful there's a and you got
your nice little double attack tactic
yeah what we're playing it now what's go
back up to move
she's my king da I was
that looks
I think the beset spawn with a check
going to a straight ending oh no oh I
can play that that's so she took with
the bishop I wouldn't have taken with
the bishop just practical reasons but
Queen takes Queen takes Johnson and you
cry but right smack alive but now King
e8 and what is going on oh my business
misplaced on that square and now why can
we no look takes d7 we can't do your
Denny Marcus what's this again rook
takes d7 I'm Queen a c7 Queen check on
b8 to pick up this little rascal oh gosh
you drop your rook back to block that
check and I got another one wonders game
no visua - now on the board defending
blocking the bit blocking the rooks
action cat it wasn't move I thought of
Caesar I've been blocking the rooks
action but rooks eat - no see to rook
takes d7 yes real tasty seven exactly be
a little careful exactly if you're what
black Joe
I like this I like this a c7 don't
forget your queen needs to protect this
guy and who gets there first white
starts yes precisely well we'll just
check you all the way from Earth like
techniques last and this is a king d8 of
the first check I'm gonna hit you with a
rook D Y in the rocky fire it's hanging
oh so you're gonna pick my rock off
check and again why does the first the
first with the checks and now you're
saying rook t2 which wasn't really well
maybe I was thinking worst case scenario
I can like I trade rooks and
yeah that's not a worst-case scenario
[Laughter]
and nonsense while you're trying to
Queen you're a pawn and blah blah blah
you don't want this you want you want to
win a little bit cleaner than just that
winning anybody anybody's hope now my
ship f2 is on the board
work is back at c4 back that up one okay
sorry
yes so now what to do now Z no doubt
cease work c2 of d7 right so she's
playing f6 f6 okay but it is two pawns
no more threats please just drop d2 on
the board to cover and protect and to
set up the dream double on the D file
twice and play the Kings like f7 and
it's not like completely yeah exactly
this yeah everything in the position
right you're begging to trade Queens if
you're black right after route B -
you're just sitting praying please trade
Queens because I'm gonna get rolled well
what am I supposed to do what's gonna
double and they're gonna go nuts okay
now she's got to pick up the pace and
turn it into the Blitz game she's got to
stop playing rapid chess and start
playing blitz she's got to do that and
there's always a time in the game when
your clock especially drops a little
five minutes that you say all right back
up a little bit it's time to play oh oh
she's mixed she's playing this a mixture
of your moves my move good some bad but
keeping the edge all the way yes keep
making it work she's not perfect and
she's playing rapid and she's not have
the benefit of just throwing out
nonsense or whatever you want to do
right she's got to play the game and she
is playing it right now definitely great
level and rookie two cements her coupon
right advantage prepares to double and
black has no moves like must trade
Queens at all costs right now Jenna look
how do I get the Queen's off because I'm
get rolled but even that line she's
gonna get rolled right easy for you to
say I have a pawn back on b7
in somehow trade queens but this
position is horrible to pass pawns
king cut off especially after we double
roofs Mitchell's gonna go on g3 you're
gonna have to trade rooks another way
when I play Bishop g3 you're gonna just
give trade and acid some time I'm seeing
the endgame and there's a clock there's
a view of the clock four minutes on the
clock better king two pawns up time
advantage no initiative for black dead
lost yeah incredible incredible she
didn't find Bishop e7 sweet but history
that's history now because she still
played chess and the great should be for
Bishop d3 beautiful lady's heart that
young lady has giant heart beating in
that chest
Wow whenever you say double X clam
enforceable he reminded it about every
tweet a expletive in between those where
every saying but that move that one
resounds Queen f2x clam before double
expound queenside castling that's not
gonna help that is not gonna help the
back foot seizing the defensive doubled
up you you play rook the rook t1
automatically here but now she's using
the 5 second delay she's she's playing
very quickly case 77 now believe it now
this means we can actually take a deep
breath and play anything I want 6 Misha
page for my SH 45 Queen a good what do
you think we see a that's that Oh
okay yeah no rook d6 is very attractive
Misha page 4 are you gonna dis for
automatic just I play I'm just gonna
take it
eyeballing the f6 bond yeah that's just
one way but I'm just deflecting your
Queen from the from the Queen yeah the
Queen side exactly so Bishop h4 looks
over yep - okay so rook a4 is the only
move my Queens almost trapped no you got
Queen e3 and wall with your room which
what is this whoa down the G light I
don't like and I'm sure she's thinking
if King f7 well I'm gonna swing the
Queen all the way over it's like a
billiard shot Queen 873 across the board
king f7 and she has played king f7 and I
know I know it's winning I'm not
thrilled with this move though I thought
she was it would be impractical for her
to play like this for example 9 f8 no -
sacrifice of rook on g6 rook on g6
you're gonna put your knight on G
putting anything on GC I'm just gonna
back up I'm gonna go back to E oh no you
have a you have G a has played your move
Knight f8 by the way Queen h6 looks
automatic what's your move now she's
played 9 f8 I mean Queen AIT's a green
nature
oh yeah Queen 86 so then you're saying
I'm not threatening rook F ruining two
three eight you think I'm threatening
rook g7 g8 King e8 I'm gonna go in the
hole King eight yeah I got you this way
Shaq you gotta take I gotta take on f8
when I got this rook d1 check coming I'm
running into the line you better find
another way to play this because that
didn't do anything rook e8 in that
position where d1 king c7 and I'm taking
the rook on e7 dude now I'm putting
Ricky 8th you're playing rook e8 yeah
thank you part 8 I don't I don't
there must be a win here the engines
win but how I don't think it's the way
you just did it well
she switched back oh oh my god 96 know
that I can know this losers now this was
a straight 97 I've created I check I've
got a 25 check I'm gonna resign that's
it beautiful move now
what does she play Queen g48 Queen G for
piling up the pressure against the d7
and now ninety seven seven but the but
it's like it's over but it's not what is
going on we can't take on D seven a play
Bishop e6 Queen gega every move looks
like pressure building she's finding all
these scents a little amazing moves
cyntha waiting just move if you're black
yeah you're like getting so strong right
now
you're real can't move right your work
on e7 I'm talking about after Oakland c4
has no moves except a for which you're
not gonna do for the rook c1 your knight
can't move because something lands on d8
the Queen has to sit still because it's
defending the knight on d7 the rook on
c4 completely actually should play the
only thing to do she could we live so
she play Queen b5 there must be a
deathblow now something like rookie time
I've looks crushing rook teeth I want to
deflect everything even a four might
work h4 no Queen back repeat what is
that about
yes explain no why did why did she she
felt like she didn't see anything down
there must have been a win though there
must have been
yeah I agree wholeheartedly with that
okay now let's settle down
it's all looking so good there has to be
I want to go back to g8 you know the
problem is white really needs to include
our bishop this posting up with the rook
with the idea of Bishop to e1 Bishop to
a5 what do you think quite a strong d1
first this should be what you want yes
Luke d5 that might a post-up move tell
us what you want invite everyone to the
party all right everybody you know what
you know what I like the move I liked it
because roof c2 I thought it may have
been some issues but now I realize you
can't play Road C 2 because there were
d7 correct so bang bang bang bang all
the way through and then it's write
everything off so that works for that
reason and I'll have a movie night GPA
night b8 and queen back down the g8
forcing Knight to d7 but that's not
gonna help me very quickly to g8 right
Knight back to c7 and now this is where
I like a trade she didn't want and now
look at this Bishop c5 she instantly
played Bishop before
that's resignation rook takes rook
allows pawn takes at the least your
looks hanging full a full rook on e7 is
gone and not to mention receive rook c1
is threatened and everything so you
cannot trade it you're gonna lose the
rook for no reason on D fact this is
residing that's it this is rezaian takes
and now it's a rook and it's resigns
right she played an amazing and by the
way 56 check we need more hoping for
nothing and then after Brooke see one
channel 1 resides anyway 1-0 in this
Armageddon playoff next round nausea
will have to win with the white pieces
Wow going at around 11 what was Annie's
performance rating at that exact moment
like 26 570 this is 2627
yeah chess and she sets up the pieces
yes she just played well all the way
through Laurence Trent said he hadn't
seen anything like her since holy fun
what a town look at that town she is
speaking with Christian 1-0 Annie Wang
gets the W but she needs to draw over we
in her next game in this playoffs to
capture the crown which seemed destined
for her earlier in this tournament and
Christian guerrilla has any Wang I'm
here with a victor of Game one of the
playoffs anyway any first of all
congratulations what a huge victory how
do you feel now good I guess I feel more
confident about my rapid playing
abilities and I'm looking forward to the
second game what was your strategy going
into this match were you able to sleep
last night actually like I was okay
yesterday I just wanted to like play my
best if I wanted that'd be great and if
I didn't like I've had like a good
tournament so far and I still be happy
with my result well congratulations and
we will see you soon
dice back to you Christian
congratulations Annie
boy was I wrong I said 60% chances for
Nagi but if Annie's gonna play like this
it's all about heart in his eye and
nerves and she was so cool that that
original position that nasi put on her
from the beginning of the game was just
so tremendous that novelty with I don't
know it was a novelty but the way she
played it look virtually new full
preparation and then Annie like a boss
come on we gotta go all the way back
okay - where's the moment when f3
happened all the way back to here
instead of D takes III should play Queen
d6 when she play this move F 3 D 3 Queen
F 294 instantly Bishop b4 Queens he said
give me the pawn and then after nighty
to Castle queenside this was the move
that signal somebody really great was
playing with the white pieces they said
I'm gonna Castle into the
what you got you got zero you could take
Missy for point if you want and that's
exactly actually what transpired traded
down and liquidated to this position
talk their King on be one and then put
in the rest of the game okay she missed
Bishop e7 but that's neither here nor
there she is playing a rapid game and
you're gonna see mistakes even the
twenty eight hundreds play and make
mistakes and rapid gains but the way she
handed herself just absolutely marvelous
or inspiring this fifteen-year-old
playing some amazing chess
if she wins it she deserves it fully to
win this title no question about it
accolades and deeds but the flip side of
that coordinate Maurice I just want to
take you back I thought this was
brilliant brilliant preparation by Nagi
I want to go back to that position where
Queen c5 as Jennifer was mentioning the
first slip if you could bring it up on
your board Nagi if she had blade that mu
queen a4 they may not have been a
defense for white but you're talking
you're talking preparation right you're
talking appropriation to your right she
got caught in something but yes sir yeah
we all get caught in stuff right
question I mean yeah she got caught in
something what's she supposed to do yeah
full preparation she went down in a
rapid game at that and the other person
knows all the moves right then yeah what
can I do you walk out of there I
remember Magnus losing to unand
it was in which which world championship
nimzo-indian yeah yeah he just got but
it was like her and he won that game
against Magnus exactly and you walk in
your the best way in the world you walk
into preparation you don't know what to
do BAM you're dead in a classical game
right so they thought that she could
have done about that right all she could
do is play the moves that are presented
to her right and it's not her fault not
0:25 it's not her fault nasi didn't take
on III nicely played D through this d3
and ninety-four idea well when she got
her chance who do not give her a chance
it's that simple don't give her a chance
f3 Queen f2 Bishop before let's trick
develop castles Queen side and boom boom
boom I mean amazing amazing the way she
seemed so poised to win this Women's
Championship and that after disaster
yesterday right
had to give the edge back to nausea but
not so much anymore as nausea is that
monster must-win situation for her with
waiting even if she wins we go to
Armageddon flats and let's seek a review
of any Wang's incredible performance
here at the u.s. women's yeah she's had
a great tournament 15 year old anyway
the youngest woman in the entire
competition
she's got math homework science English
homework and oh by the way she's leading
the US Women's Championship it is a
winning and game for Annie now game
after game after game it's been amazing
watching her I'm gonna make a little bit
of a projection they young any way could
find herself in the first place clear
disco game today but her defense held
and she played brilliantly to secure not
just the draw but the win what she
really kept was hope I can still stay in
the game and find the best moves even
though I'm lost and that's something
that you know is the mark of a champion
keep fighting she's doing great so far
and I think she just used all her
chances really well she's not a
strategist she's not somebody who comes
up with big attacks and sacrifices bones
with the initiative but she isn't a
tenacious defender that's arena crushed
she's playing right and she is making
this work hard will she find it she's
done it oh my little Marilee outplayed
her Annie is playing out of her mind
right now what a boss
or in that lovely clip I mean you really
get the instinct that she seizes the
opportunity and I mean I got it we have
to review what just happened at the end
there because there was some moves that
she was playing that would just
brilliant move after move
that's right Bishop e1 was one of my
favorite movie was just about to crack
open nausea and she needed a little bit
more firepower right and even with just
a minute on our clocks she found it
should be long I know what incredible
instincts let's take a look at the very
end of that game this is where I trade
she didn't want and now look at this
Bishop c5 she instantly played Bishop
before that's resignation rook takes
rook allows pawn takes at the least your
looks hanging full a full rook on e7 is
gone and not to mention rook see we're
actually one is threatened and
everything so you cannot trade it and
you're gonna lose the rook for no reason
on the that's it this is rook and it's
resigns right she played an amazing and
by the way 56 check we need more hoping
for nothing anyway 1:0 in this
Armageddon playoff next round Navi will
have two guys that was an exciting
exciting we've got another game in store
- oh my pounding heart you you you take
that one
she asks you I'd love it I'd love to see
you know me I would love to see how we
get into but with Annie Wang playing so
wow that was an amazing game I'm always
rooting for her Magana yeah the most
exciting thing for the championship to
be so closely contested that there's no
other way to decide it exactly that's
why we have it hmm well I cheated today
we will find out though in a few minutes
here as I think they're gonna be
starting their second game of this mini
match very shortly and here we have it
an Aussie pick Izzy and Annie Wang are
playing their next game anyone with
white in the first line and what will
happen in the second we'll find out in
just a few minutes then we'll come back
for commercial break
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues what about after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
stead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us and you guys
know I can't play this right st. Lou is
always exploring this August the best
chess players in the world are coming to
st. Louis for the grand chest tour st.
Louis rapid and blitz and Sinquefield
Cup tournaments will feature the world's
best right here in st. Louis st. Louis
chess club's celebrating its 10th
anniversary and these tournaments will
be a highlight you won't want to miss
for tickets and more information go to
st. louis chess club org
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. chess
championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the World Chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
[Music]
professional Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion for those of you who are
new to chess it might look like VA 3 is
an illegal move here because white
advances point to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
gotta say clay King in seven games e2
and now try because all play four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed the playing during the course
of my steak yeah he told me this is that
d5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think we practiced I
know who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if just
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
[Music]
we're back at the US Women's
Championship a playoff between nausea
Kinsey and Annie rang any Wang started
this two game at match off with a
wonderful victory Reed and nas he's
gonna have to get her back with the
victory in this game - forcing
Armageddon oh now she's back as to the
wall Jennifer Maurice you know I love
commentating with you but I've got to
tell you the shows have been great
because of the players I mean that game
was so entertaining to watch it was
amazing
to call and as we say your back to the
wall you got to bring your best and here
we go for the game - don't forget that
this is the first time that naazy lost
in those championships he went and took
a playoffs but is the first time she
lost and she does not lose these easily
and again it was a rapid play but the
way she lost was unbelievably must be
devastating to get crushed like that you
remember it you feel it like the shock
of it just to clear her mind and play
this game and we have a fortress set up
d five castles they should be seven the
players absolutely it looks like we're
going into a Kings Indian attack a
Fisher favorite hoping that her younger
less experienced player will make
mistakes in close types of formation and
we have efore on the board and do we
have a move after evil nope it's Annie
they've both playing author delay it was
a plague v6 yeah it was a game played in
the championship it's Nakamura Nakamura
and Lenderman Alec Slenderman and the
idea is white wants to establish his
pawn on e5 get rid of this very
important defender of the Kings side
this knight on f6 put your rook on e 1
and then it's student body right
everybody goes Kings side for white and
black usually has to delay the
development of the King
if you declare your intentions too early
and put your king on the kingside white
is going to bring everybody after the
king
so with this move B 7 B 6 a knee is
occasionally keeping our options open
maybe she'll Castle long maybe she'll
keep her King in the center for quite
some time to come
but rook e1 is the automatic move here
in this position and I think that
sometimes it's sort of feeling like
nausea is out preparing herself a little
bit where when the preparation starts to
go away from what she's used to she
hasn't played great we've seen her catch
people of preparation before remember
the game against Tata if she played the
move b5 in the Carroll Kahn
yes 3 b5 and then she didn't follow it
absolutely exactly and got herself into
trouble exactly and I seem to recall
another game I was like that was a game
against any it was a game against anyone
she had the white pieces again and
played this sharp line and was very
happy and never got to play the move g4
and she and she play d5 early so it's
not you know she wants an original
position but she hasn't been following
it up with the most precise thematic
ways to play again and she's ladies
ladies rook e1 and came bishop be Queen
c7 came Queen c7 Queen e2 and then
Bishop to b7 Queen c7 Bishop Queen c7
Queen e2 Bishop d7 I'm up to date with
them with the board you are know now in
this situation black is preparing
castles but it's more important that
black is preparing this move g5 right
and it's it's a critical critical that
white play h2h for here white doesn't
play H 2 H 4 I've played these positions
numerous times in that career as black
and I know that if I get in g5 and
Castle I've got the initiative yes and
again like I said if you just try to put
some original position on the board you
know I'm just gonna play this line I
don't want to straight off anything I
don't wanna walk into a theory you could
find yourself in a position that you're
not familiar with all the nuances
strategic and tactical and your point
being you've seen this before your
experience with it I know you must stop
this move so h4 should be screaming at
her plate now and not think exactly
she's starting to think about this
position how do I handle it and she does
not play it c4 c4 knife Annie has played
this before his black that we don't know
if she has played this before and she
decides to drop g5 on the board now she
does have to calculate what 35 yeah
takes on d5 and e6 well the idea here is
the eventual home is thank you for
exactly the eventual home for blacks
King is on the Queen side so let's shut
down the action over there locked lock
it down so that the king is nicely safe
and tucked away on the Queen side point
out why this now gee if I wasn't a g5
would have actually rebounded because an
attack on the flank I can best be met by
an attack in the center and takes takes
six and suddenly black is in deep deep
trouble that was why we saw the move D
54 and then again H 2 H 4 is screaming
you need to play H 2 H 4 and then 94
Bishop f4 try to capitalize on those
darfs well I'd love to put the money for
I simply can't yeah you pun will be
hanging in those positions simply can't
never gonna be able to well no more you
got a time Bishop f4 and then I'll go
back to e4 maybe give me nine if one
night nine f1 manure yes exactly it was
an important move right now it's it's so
critical although we could always take
on c5 and like trade everything off but
that's not what we're after
no when we're trying to get that heap on
f1 immediately whew Knight f1
immediately h7 h6 showing that she is
she is and he knows the idea of g5 again
h4 is so important is he for is if I'm
still playable if you play it's for you
yes but in this case if I play h4 which
I absolutely need to play g5 is still
playable because after takes takes the
problem is I'm gonna play Knight to h2
followed by Knight to g4 and then I'm
going to start thinking about capturing
this pawn on g4 she finally H 2h 4 has
appeared on the board a very key moment
in and then he's gonna anyway Castle
queenside again is the one thing you
cannot do is Castle kingside
that is suicidal so it's between playing
g5 and perhaps after Knight h2 castling
at that moment or just cackling right
away right but if you Castle right away
Knight h2 or Bishop anyway no Bishop f4
is also a key consideration but okay
castles white two games in a row as for
it haloth queen sized oh that's coming
up for anyway and for both Nagi also had
to cancel Queen says so let's go to the
fine Jesus I've g5 is critical it's okay
I'm taking principled movie or taste
takes and I'm playing takes takes 980
Castle please don't immediately yeah I
thought you chica player with rook aged
five and double rooks and it's hard to
figure out how white gets easy progress
there that was the point there was I
think g5 is coming anyway how are you
stopping a g5 idea but she Castle
queenside after and that yes we have on
the board with na z to play but I gotta
like the outcome of the opening for na z
overall that she got a position with so
little trades with so many imbalances
all the pieces are on the board and
clearly since victory is the only thing
that keeps her in the match I think I
would be happy also that exactly with
the type of position kind of like when
Fabiano played against ero in the US
Championship menu to win to
realistically stay in contention and he
got this type of situation as well with
castling and opposite sides now here
what I'm thinking from White's point of
view first of all I do want to secure
the evite part I want
plate 9 h 2 GG 4 and then i want to play
a 3
she's pretty try though this will slow
down the idea of g5 well I don't like it
I like Knight h2 because if you play g5
in that exact position I'll shut you
down
now with the move h5 and Knight g4 means
that this pawn on h6 is always a target
for the rest of the game and strategic
gains have been made on the Kings side
by white this move h h5 for me as a
little bit premature allows the g6 break
eventually right so something to say g6
right will open up partially open up
lines and widest against White's King
yes and white is still struggling to
prove where she's opening up line so
rook it's ok whoa ro f8 rook she can't
be planning f6 that would be a strategic
error may be fighting g6 and opening up
lot the F line giving herself counter
play along the F line so she's put her
rook but this when you play move like
rook f8 Jennifer it really is
you're showing that you're playing for
f6 which isn't I think she's playing
that nimzowitsch
mysterious move and a-two a-three okay I
like this move White is intimating that
look I'm gonna play Bishop d2 and I'm
playing for b4 keep in mind that pawn on
a7 is and protect before immediately as
possible right
well you'll take yeah yeah yeah it's -
no so basically with this move and as
you say go ahead and play 6 make my day
I don't think what f6 really
I know since it's random you can't play
up stakes yesterday GC she's trying to
play g5 and just yet known on g5 g
fighting shutting down your own attack
yes Jesus g6 and she might get bit so
play oh my gosh did she fight she is
played g5 now the move
that fate makes no sense you know I'm
looking at night H to remove the night
that's 1/2 H - 2 G for table 4 for some
time you play for work almost anywhere
else we could play Bishop g7 maybe and
at least pressure that pawn you have but
the knight on g4 is such a masterpiece
it ok so 9 X 2 F 6 has to be played
because you playing randomly otherwise
right ok so so she just adjusted her
apology I was about to say okay so let's
go nice - 9 H 2 and F 6 because
otherwise it's not what's what's the and
then I played Knight g4 tickling the
rook go away and that e-cigs pawn is
dropping off the board and that might
just be that's enough to stop the show
yeah exactly
so after Knight h2 something besides f6
probably I really I hesitate because I
just put my work and I hate but what now
I want to put my Bishop on g7 correct
you put it yeah you're like let's let's
take our move back so yeah but now now
that this whole King site is set shut
down now I start to think about pawn
sacrifices with b4 on tap I'll play
Bishop to d2 okay finally I get to play
Bishop g7 Bishop g7 and I'm I'm over
here on the now I can open up lines on
the Queen side and the King side I'm
tying you down to e5 but you still have
the right number of defenders yes okay
there's an amazing line which would be
hard to imagine that she would find
after g5 what is the variation we are
here we have six so so to play f6 ef6
right and to play this really ridiculous
looking at move Knight takes f6 right
allowing Queen e6 check and then
securing the position right of your king
the point is that you're threatening
this move 985 and you
get everything and the King can also
because I mean the Queen could also
become a little bit of a liability in
this position this for an old Bobby
Fischer sacrifice Knight takes g5 oh you
read too many books is positive seeing
Bobby Bobby has massacred yes then you
can take and that's the surplus three
pawns for the position so and Bishop f4
is on tap is on tap there you go so yeah
on the shoulders of giants you play G
for instead that move I think the idea
behind g4 if she wanted to put her night
on g3 and eyeballing the potential efore
down listen I really don't allow this to
move f5 now she just signal begging her
opponent to play at five f5 is a huge
response put it on the board g4 f5 and
now when you capture you've you allow
rook takes and you don't get to capture
on on you don't have that tickle with 94
ya don't get to play Knight G forever
and and now we're just gonna open this
is an open ticket to the F file down the
board but she did not play it she played
king b8 first allowing Bishop to d2 she
needs to realize that f5 is a super
strong move and the most she wants to
play but she does not realize it she
knows she wants to play our five well
you got to open up the position
laundress and the soul of our game
gotta play a5 go for it even if six is
good right just open up the F line and
get your counter play don't sit back be
daring no draw don't worry about drawing
the game and anyway White's threatening
to build with b4 anyway so exactly
you're not gonna get counter play you're
not gonna stop what White's doing on the
other side that's just not gonna happen
so you need to get yours even if you
have to give up the weak eat six pawn or
give up a weakness of e6 go for the gold
here f5 or f6 just play she is a gold
medalist for the
no she knows how to go for gold and I
think she's gonna come across the right
plan here yes because it's the plan in
the position without side to let her we
talked about a pawn play and of course
our new us champions did worried about
Jesus gone no but I I like this choice -
because she's falling back on Jennifer's
idea like when the night was on g4 the
pawn on e5 was perfectly insulated to
protect it now that I can't get the
Knight to g4 or even the bishop to f4
this idea of Jennifers sorry company
work and encounter play yes okay okay
well before doesn't lead any let's say
no let's just say rook b1 okay and let's
imagine that and he says I don't believe
in what you're doing
b4 I'm just gonna go Bishop g7 and I'm
gonna target this guy they'll be for is
on the board I can take faster one c5
there and if you take with a knight that
takes away one of your attackers at the
pawn you take with the pawn and no I'm
taking with the knife okay just to keep
key please before right away right away
okay you know me I'm a pawn got some
phone sex
i recon sack and she's captured I'm
taking and going for it is naazy trying
to get a seven this should take the
bishop yes Bishop takes looks like you
will have to prove yourself because a
nice gonna land on c5 and exactly some
serious shutdown on that side of the
board right it once at night lands on c5
hitting the pawn on d3 - by the way it
comes with bonus points and a pawn will
go to a5 even oh and and dare you figure
out how to get in this position what
happens after Knight takes d4 Thutmose
oh whoa whoa whoa maybe we're being a
little bit too fast Knight takes d4
because I suddenly spied an idea of rook
takes a seven a lot of nice
hold on okay I want to take on g2 in
this exact yeah okay yeah I can see why
now I just have to pause because sorry
exactly I just wanted to pause okay but
you know me I'm gonna be 95 runs like
Queenie five okay I'll take a piece and
she has delayed not Bishop takes but
Knight takes before we're in a position
it's gonna have no she didn't play
Bishop all she played 1996 before d4 I
didn't
I taste they do not feel right this now
this now is white as extra move keeping
the extra option right well you you
shouldn't think with a night six squares
gonna be very tender in that line but
Bishop takes g2 okay we're looking at me
295 right but I'm gonna take on g2 okay
because Queen e5 was the problems yet 25
is is the way to bailout right offering
the trader Queen and I don't want to
bail I want to get all the people you
want to make sure that black isn't it
five and but now the threat is night to
be night b5 as a boss threat a5 a5 a5 I
know it sucks it's ugly but you're gonna
have to sack to break my position down
[Music]
tonight I'm gonna post the night here on
b5 Adam place post the other night on e4
and I'm gonna play it with c3 d4 white
will just completely take over the game
that's why f5 was so important and that
rook on h8 now look ridiculous as all of
my cells are working some wobbly moves
there to f8 back to EA those were to
Tempe loss we do
she's very practical player she tries
not to get behind in the cloth but the
negative side of that is sometimes
drifting 96 night back to c6 is on the
board guys okay right so I am NOT okay
as an attacker do not trade
unnecessarily backwards oh that's okay
I want to play a five right now I think
you need to get that move in really
really immediately soon because right
way that move forever here definitely
looks like a much better move than a
five I like nice e6 is very yeah it's
putting pressure on e5 and it's
defending a7 as well without creating
more weaknesses exactly so yeah
obviously this game is still going to be
very rare Oh joking when I said
Armageddon Kali
lots of time so we're in just a very
rich position and I will point out the
engine things that the best move right
now is Knight takes c6 I just took a
glance that is not a move I don't wanna
play 96 doesn't look logical actually f3
to follow it up that is not human I
don't see that happening on this
chessboard but that's the engines
proposal eyes the best way to play this
position I don't see that I mean I mean
it's not intuitively obvious that you
want to give up that night that
attacking night but once you start
looking at it yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
once we start looking at and we know the
engines been crunching billions of
possibilities we know it's a good idea
oh you could sense it's a good idea but
that I don't see that move being played
well yeah because plane may take c6
allowing a recapture we could check
right is counter-intuitive you've got to
sit awhile to realize that that is the
right thing to do it's hard to imagine
you're doing it intuitively I think
she's gonna be looking at other options
before coming back to that one and
saying okay maybe that's what I have to
do but to do it immediately is unnatural
it makes you explain more of the logic
behind the move between Toshi
so much for thinking for a while not
mine f3 is that it's actually kind of
passive and when you do get to play off
six my knight is sitting there in the f5
alright so this is actually more logical
when you get a chance to really think
about it so kudos to Navi yeah
definitely I was greedily thinking I
wanted to play d4 d5 advance those pawns
with the tempo against the knight on c6
but now she has captured and played F 2
F 3 F 5 folks come on gotta go to go
because you're almost required to play a
5 because if the bishop comes to c3 this
knight on f1 is jumping right to that
key outpost on the e4 square and you
need counterplay so that's why f5 or f6
she had so many opportunities to play f5
and unleash it and she hasn't done it
yet because he just been treating this
epon as a weakness she's playing finally
she's decided on a break because she
really she saw a bishop c3 coming in
once that comes it might be too late
exactly so she it was this time now or
never exactly now we're never indeed I
think if I was stronger because it
threatened to take on g4 and it prompts
the exchange giving no choices I like
this one too
this one is there a way that white can
exploit f6 you're saying that the threat
of f5 as we saw in the commercial from
trust 24 you can only do the on decide
who's where this is a kind of nice
little trick you play at 6 and if for
some reason she does something else do
you get the play up on she takes an f6
has occurred Bishop f6 by anyway exactly
oh but now she has so much play look at
that Bishop and that rook come to life
that were sleeping before as well okay
rook a to I I wasn't a hundred percent
sure I was thinking also rook a3 to keep
the pawn protected but clearly by
playing the move rook a to Nagi is
thinking that at some point in the
future shall chase
Bishop off the diagonal to play rook a 1
and double rooks against the a pawn
right maybe not you know Annie's idea
maybe Bishop D 495 Rick f8 put maximum
pressure on the pawn on f3
no question about that I mean you're
gonna have to stick your knight on e4
but the knight its glory on e4 so and
we're we're expecting Knight g3 okay
Bishop d4 that Bishop on d4 so good I
just got to get rid of it I'm sorry okay
I'm just gonna play Bishop e3 and try to
get rid of that Bishop put my knight on
e4 and on a very good day five but
because I'm hacking on f3 with three
different things but I think you can
just get away with playing can you get
away with just playing Bishop takes
Bishop here I'm not sure nice except
three you're threatening this guy no
there's there's a queen e4 and the
position might and then well but you
can't and I can take on d4 exactly so
these tactics are very interesting as
but the point is if I if I rip open
you're over here just the mercury went
down it's not like the direction you
guys what oh that's a double yeah yeah
excuse me it's my I feel like I feel
like black should be putting the knight
on c5 and because the f3 pawn looks like
it can be defended eventually meanie
okay even if you get so this is the
creative situation but if I okay cuz c5
defends as well but II five hits d3 and
f3 and might force your rook on to be
passive f1 position you might run out of
steam in that position so what are we
thinking about what's the evening was
the night on c5 85 so we wouldn't
require us to stick a bishop on d4 so
that's the good part it only takes one
move instead of two Maurice you you want
the knight on c5 Bishop e3 was noisy
smooth I know but what brings a perk FA
okay Bishop e3 right away sorry
so the knight is actually on f1 yes
she's trying to stop the dish 54 idea
right and also maybe she's here now I
can't 95 runs into d4 as well d4 no you
don't want that happening anytime soon
and what about 95 cuz that threatens the
d4 pawn as well e5 I like that look
because that as you say is a tempo with
against that guy g4 and f3 I really
don't like sticking my knight on H no
fun no no no you don't want your knight
on h2 the weight the weight no rook a 1
no I can't play rook a 1 what about fish
no that doesn't work
Sakon try to get through in the v/line
yes exactly that's our spidey sense is
saying something yeah yeah we're looking
at sacrifices but this is a double-edged
position on the board
get excited nations to not equal to
Howell - and she played it quickly but
our knight into this this jail cell here
and the Atlantic sea 4 and a 3 but hey
those are two good points to defend yeah
yeah the good thing about this is even
though it looks really bad
I like them wait the fact that the
bishop is on I have six not
participating because the knight is in
the way and obviously if we ever move
the knight you're gonna go straight back
to f1 do you want G G 384 exactly she's
playing her kind of stabilize the
position she stabilized the position if
y black runs out of moves then all of a
sudden d4 and some breaks e5 and start
right I like the seats entacle so the
problem for the right now the problem
for black is if you don't have what is
your long-term plan right like this this
is nice to have a little demonstration
and your knight is sitting on a look
like in a stem so they go square but
your Bishop on f6 is not working the
rook on f8 is not working all that has
been shut down and just a quick couple
of moves and now how do you get counter
play but d4 is coming so far
d dat for I may not play these for I
want to go see five I want to try to
break open with C 5 I think you
attracting anyone with check what's
wrong with continuing the build what's
wrong with rook d1 or anyone think oh I
was just thinking that my plan there is
black would be to try to double ruff how
about if I wrote d1 on the D file I'm
gonna play wrote what d7 look at seven
rook f7 this is what Maurice is saying
then you're gonna get the play d4 anyway
okay your knight doesn't have well
actually there is a threat to check mass
21 yes and I'm just afraid but lacks
initiative is gonna dry up and write the
moment white stars rolling the pawns
it's all white yeah not look C to D 4
and then C 5 doesn't look pretty it's
doing it's just holding the fort it's
all the way back and then if your
deflected by moving your work then you
can come in to the game as well it's on
formation right now it looks better for
white to pawn islands vs. 3 the e6 pawn
is weak all end games lead to White's
advantage the opponent eight-six is also
a problem in the long term and there
might even be some funny sacrifice on g5
if you're not paying attention because
they run away it doesn't run away and
also might be a double sacking that
night never comes back f1 g3e for then
that sacrifice is gonna be on top in any
end game so black really I think white
the security of whites King versus the
insecurity potential of blacks King is
starting to speak in this position and
and it's really about the initiative
drying up if blacks initiative dries up
why it's gonna make some very easy moves
in the middle of the board 57 again
let's take a look at how that all turns
out as Rick d7 and works you too good
move run d8 and then just d4 that's
gonna push my knight back I don't have
any tactical way because you are if the
name takes honey you are 36 95 for the
moment because you're beginning to
choose
if I move the way you won't actually be
able to take it cuz I have okay just get
the night out of the way now here is
where wife would just be in her glory if
that night could ever get back to the e4
square we move our knight in the pawn is
hanging so do you want player key to or
you got something else in mind I'm
looking at d5 actually yeah I didn't see
if I both need to be looking at if I try
to crank things open that's what I was
tasting can i Craig can I pray open
position where can I be 7 yes and let me
drop in with a hello hello how is it
how's a queen c6 we can't let that pawn
I had a beautiful package yeah I see six
or sixty one and c7 check let's take a
look okay come on these players are by
the way managing their tags beautifully
as usual twelve minutes left on the
clock for each player they they don't
really tank as much as we would see from
some other players in the Women's
Championship and it's really creating
some well play games from for rapid oh
gosh yes oh my god okay Oh King a she's
getting off a beeline in case of c5
she's gene a yeah but that does not look
like how she walking into Bishop takes
b6 type of ideas you know what this
reminds me of everybody you know no I'm
uh she played that little King a 1 and
reminds me uncle
it reminds me of Gaspar off the Trojan
No yeah cuz far off the Trojan when when
Kasparov was massing a King side attack
around petrosian's
Queen side like yes and and and
Petrossian played the move b5 with the
king sitting on BIA was Tilburg yeah
it's one of the most famous games a Wow
what an incredible game have you guys
look that up and the way that roses
that I was like what are you doing
that's just insane and yet it turned out
to be brilliant and cos Faro just felt
like the power I'm gonna kill you and
then they kick marked even the c6
flooded by white pieces just circling
like vultures and couldn't find a shot
and it was as nothing recommend this
defense so this is maneuver where she's
saying you know what let me just get I'm
gonna allow you some things but I'm
gonna back away
so she's played King ec2 so I could
support the move d4 bit but that was
reportedly rook c8 ultra prophylaxis
against the potential d4 that's like
this she's playing way too slow I know
she's doing she's getting a rook into
the game now rook to be won with an
instant threat on b6 that is a big
tickle I know it's time you get that
night on h2 back into the game I never
liked that night on high by the way then
I don't need five just seems so
artificial temporary so that's right it
just felt like you didn't belong c5 it
looked like where you belong and then
bring the rooks to the D line and put
something on d4 the bishop on d4 trade
off like it made more sense
night night f1 bring that guy back to
the e4 square there's a clock times what
are the clock ten minutes for an Aussie
and about eleven for an e they're pretty
so pretty balanced o clocks on the clock
yeah nine F 1 2 D 2 to e4 or 2 G 3 to e4
bring the unhappy piece and put him to
work
put that knight on e4 and I like White's
position if he effects that maneuver yes
absolutely worst piece worst place piece
bring it into how do we get counter play
we have to play something like she
played very aggressively sick bringing
bishop b6 maybe queen a tree maybe your
queen coming to a2 is her idea right now
hey the King might have to go back
looks like a really powerful move the
King might just have to go back and get
out of this line because you don't want
to play moves like Bishop the a tour
route b8 and just corner yourself made
it somehow on the a file no you're gonna
need to play rook c7 event early know if
you go king b8 I got Bishop g3 check
kinds of ideas to this may have been
fine much superior to my desired night
f1 g3 for idea because this is just a
huge attack Queen a2 is on tap and any
so maybe king b7 and rook e8 is that
illegal man King know that King b7 wow
that is really asking for everybody 7
that some kind of that looks terrible
Queen e2 is if you play I don't
threatening Bishop right everybody we
don't relish to play very much 66 rook
c6 it's possible cuz you know the rock
off you move the bishop huh been
troubling along Queen e2 has been played
by the 66 I go d4 yeah and I'm thinking
triple on the a file what do you want
from me I know I go to play Knight ugly
b8 so I can make my trip to the a file I
don't want to do it but yes yes okay oh
my gosh what is she thinking b8
at least you can play Bishop e5 against
something but this looks like some guy
no I'm sorry for with the idea of c59
yeah here come the entire war raging
grants Bishop g3 on tap for good this is
terrible you know the thing is the thing
is that black uh one thing we've seen
about Annie is that she's had trouble
with the black pieces she's been
wonderful with white but she has had
trouble with the black pieces she had
lost positions against Galletti ani that
she managed to turn around and win she
also had a lost position what was that
but who did she play with black where
she had tremendous service showed that
she was getting creamed remember that
game right Chavez came right after she
had 96 defense she has played Bishop
today she's had trouble with black she
might not this sure of her black
defenses because she's just been getting
hunted I wonder what color she gets next
mageddon game will count what color she
has she's been much more incisive with
the white pieces and trouble with the
black pieces in fans Afanasieff I could
see right now are saying go naazy this
is a big comeback for the 2016 generate
the idea what she wanted to meet Bishop
g3 with Bishop c7 there's a rook a one
remember that Bishop on f6 was
controlling that a1 square rook a one if
you get if you're forced to play rook c7
no forget it
then Bishop g3 for ghosting up and c5
two on tap very high chance of going
garment heaven about her color and how
auntie's doing so great with the white
pieces is that when you play with the
white pieces you have to win so if she
does a win the flip and get white and
she's waiting in the army game so I the
normal pick is the big flag of course
but because of her tournament record
will she go and pick white if she wins
the flip Wow that'll be a really
interesting decision well this is
exciting one of these ladies if Ghazi
closes this out will have to win it in
overtime right just incredible that
we've gone to this punching back one to
the other one a blow followed by another
and here is nasi she is as play this
very solidly
and made sure no counter play for
black-black sure to play that f5 move so
long ago it's not even funny
right but hey I just like we always say
I can only play the moves that my
opponent allows you
that's a look that's an exchange at
least I love this Bishop on you know on
f2 just eyeballing this b6 where you
know I want to play c5 and look at
blacks pieces the rook on f8 97 ultra
defensive and I've got ideas like Queen
e6 I've got ideas like c6 I've got ideas
of capturing topic look at this these
threats wait c5 what about my queen defy
just to fight you Queen d5 giving up the
a pond I'm not sure you can get 5 is on
the board yeah well let's see let's just
give it a quick see look see I'm gonna
take on a7 you're gonna take on a to
getting rid of the Queen's doing your
best but look at this I got I got me
jump rope checks flooding into I don't
see this is close move somehow but yeah
how am I gonna make moves
dickham if you take on c5 I'll recapture
in York and poor Inez King I made it
here but how to make more move it how to
defend otherwise yeah I don't I don't I
mean you were not happy playing Queen d5
but it was their choice you know that's
the best part about the attack you force
your opponent to exchange on your jobs
or your terms
so notice Queen d5 you turn you took on
87 saying you exchange that's something
people don't understand when they are
material we don't material don't try to
trade make keep making good moves and
when your opponent is desperate they're
gonna ask to trade and then you go oh
really that's what I wanted to do in the
first place right so don't just play for
trades that's a bad idea
the principle of I'm out material
therefore I will trade no yes you trades
are good for you that's all you need to
think about trades are good for you but
you're up your opponent is going to be
desperate so if they start offering your
trades you just said okay keep keep
offering guess what
I'm out material yeah so that's how
that's a very important principle to
know they're both at seven minutes but
that's not going to matter that much in
this position it's just not you can play
like see six men were k-8 and we'll see
seven for k7 meet with the right right
and don't forget Bishop g3 is just
lurking in the position takes c6 Knight
on h2 is just laughing yeah that's just
do any work defender it's cool there's
nothing happening guarding for butthole
hey guys we you got it you got it to
stop and pay respects Nagi back against
the wall is playing an amazing game and
we have rookie co-champions but that's
not going to happen rook e8 guarding the
pawn willing willing to give up the rook
on c7 but you know g3 I think g5
prepared and then I'm Maurice Bishop
Terrebonne just a comedy six making a
point
oh my goodness you gotta take this ball
right on and gift a gift again easy
there I take the rook number key 6 right
oh no I can't there you can't and E 6
will come with thunder ok can I go on
exchange down and survive somehow with
Queen trade no Queen Queen d5 you play
rugby 6 check a wingding my rookie 6
check is automatically well we're
already this is lost
rice is dead loss now as he just has to
find the moves and it shows the heart of
both these players we known as he's got
a tremendous fighting spirit she won
this championship before we've seen it
and now she's shown what happens is you
take a punch and then come back it's
Annie didn't do what she was supposed to
do with the f5 rate but again that's too
bad you got to play the right moves what
am I talking about this is terrible I
can just I can just blast open the f2
tag
whoa Bishop takes b6 rook a8 mate is
about to land in the position and she
Rossi one that takes off the pressure
whoo that move no no Roxy one put it on
the work this this Queen d5 that's
desperate defense that's not okay yeah
no well they know when the exchange but
that I'll take but okay well the pain
that I was I'd rather see that happen no
she oh because you really good moves
because that you know even though you're
up in exchange if you're not breaking
through white black does have two
connected passed pawns I know you gonna
laugh but to connect the department
maybe just one on the Queen side right
and we'll get some kind of punching
chances
okay so rook see one on the board Queen
d5 she might not play it because she
goes down in exchange that's right oh
wait a minute I should go down a change
yeah hold on J treat what have I King b7
there's a c6 and a mate on it no it's
not made on anyone I take on d8 you take
on a6 I don't have them made on anyone
you could see things coming yeah right
ace on d5 and now the line we were
looking at his Bishop g3 Kia but she
buddy v she's not the Queen d5 rather
she play d5 well Annie was clearly
afraid of this impossible of Bishop g3
which is why she wanted to shut down
that diagonal but is no Queen f7 is not
and without c6c6c6 Queen c6 work 87 I'll
give you that it's not dead I'll give
you that yeah 85 85 is a fight he 5 is
before she to think force you to think
you better come up with a move defines
not possible c6 is a different kind of
line this is this is Josh it's possible
this is
bringing the pond yes III like all of
our other lines that they're not all of
sense can I fly Bishop f6 and reply and
she has played Bishop G 3d vision of six
I don't need the vessel that might be an
I don't need the bishop on d8 anymore I
mean it's bad but what are you what are
you planning
Bishop D Bishop f6 makes a lot of sense
yeah the engine definitely hates it but
I don't know about States I'm looking at
the fact that the we're gonna eat in the
everything all your pieces seem to be so
loose here so Queen takes c6 rook takes
a seven is your idea Jeff and I'm
turning queen of seven and all like well
you know seven or take your rook Panisse
are true and then I'd have Queenie aap I
want something this is a mouse
counterpunching yeah yeah yeah take this
any day a week let's do this
I've got Queen sweetie to shrek is
calling I don't know now that we have
now that we're at the stake yeah that
rook c1 was a long was a wobble yeah
guys now that we're stopping to think to
try to figure out what to do
yeah that's a bad sign yes that means
now Z's thinking as well and she's only
got three minutes three and a half for
about four minutes for each player she
has me to move though what was it um
well mission for you three I can be
ready saw that though haven't seen [ __ ]
about secured Mattie oh I see so no it's
it's bad for sure but Bishop f6 wow this
is so tense this is an incredible moment
Bishop to g3 Lord Bishop f6 then the
best move big time move Knight f1 oh you
were trying to make that maneuver
earlier you're a nut horsey into the
game and that's gonna be all she wrote
and that is a powerfully in
see it the guy was a hanging out now
it's time and that night will just waltz
into the game and crack the positions of
Bishop f6 if played we put that on the
board business ignite f1 and you have no
counter play although I must say Knight
if one does a lot no see six and she
played rook to c6 maybe she didn't like
another maneuver but she's played work
c6 instead of Bishop f6 that that allows
old switcheroo near okay one back in
business
forcing you to go back to defend that
pawn there's a hole which is what I
wanted in the first place
yeah the rooks all lined up beautifully
on the 8th also rook a one will force
rook c7 back yep yeah ok that's easy
that one is a cruncher ok that was a big
slip 97 instantly that was just a loss
of moves by Harris was more tenacious
even though it was losing this one it
just made it too easy to give away a
couple of free moves exactly wanted the
rook to be back on the C once right and
now she just has to feel but you don't
want it the thing is about 9f one is I'm
back to this efore thing it's like I
want to play for but everything drops
efore immediately loses to work a7
correct
so 791 you can't play anymore because
the rook a 7 and you're toast night f1
to e4 to d6 that's all and she has taken
she's taken on b6 taken on B 619 Spacek
instantly mani you can also just take
with the bishop right
yeah but I'm thinking take she's done
yeah we were looking at that line with
pawn takes right right rook takes e5
sacking the exchange pawn takes d5 all
been played three and a half minutes for
each player we talked about Petrosian
earlier and Petrosian exchange sacrifice
has been executed not on the great
circumstances not under any
okay so what about something like
bringing the night in now Knight d5 I
know it's dangerous looking but 95
starts to threaten some things I always
cook see to check in the position so are
some tricks in the position you a little
careful that is that would be a trick to
fall for right weensy eight I believe
threatening will be six it does work be
maybe six piece is made into six is to
because of if you the rook isn't mate
they just play it done that's it resigns
absolutely and we're gonna draw for
Armageddon lots right now you know if
you the funny thing is if you're gonna
become champion you got to go through a
champion she had to play go luciani she
had to play arena crush she had to play
na z she had to play as a ton ski she
had to play so being a foreigner she
went through all that and now she's
playing nothing twice and then three
times you don't win this championship
without showing your stuff and now is he
saying uh uh
young lady I've done this before this is
game fourteen guys working for nausea
and a knee and it's gonna be the last
game here two Rapids and we're gonna go
up to Tony rich right now for the
drawing of the Armageddon lock oh my
word welcome back to the playing hole
we're tied up one two one after the two
rapid games so the players after a
15-minute break will begin their
Armageddon game where black has draw
adds it White has a time advantage so to
draw colors this time around we have
Annie Wang with our chief arbiter Ken
blue she chose the left hand which
contains the black pawn so any will have
the black pieces and draw odds against
snazzy
all right thank you very much 15 minutes
you know what I mean in an Armageddon I
wanna I wanna I want black but as White
has won both games maybe I want Y and
but here are the rules Jennifer
well white starts of five minutes plus a
two second in command black starts at
four minutes coats a two second
increment and black is the clear the
winner integer all of this is a little
bit more favorable than traditional
Armageddon structures where there's not
always that two second increment exact
so that's why if you would normally pick
black in a draw then you're gonna arm
again imagine definitely pick black with
these precise rules but because yeah
extra minute with the two seconds
increment dozen is not as effective now
sometimes in the Artic at Armageddon
match you pick to choose right so you
pick a if you pick the wipe-on you'll
say I'm black exactly or yeah exactly
and if you pick the black pony other
player chooses in this drawing of lots
it seems like just determine exactly
right yeah would have been interesting
to see what Annie picked I actually
think that she agreed with you guys and
that despite the the kind of traditional
and a more obvious pick being black I
think she would have picked white if she
had the pick what do you think I could
she looked a little disappointed when
she got the black bond to me I'm in
recovery I can black I think about
taking black in that situation I think
she would have picked black I think she
would have people at because the black
pick is the superior pick yeah with the
draw odds with the draw odds it means
that you have two results exactly so
that is such a big number 66 percent of
the results favor you and only 33
percent favor the favors the other
person so you wanna you want to maximize
your chances and the time edge if you're
a decent blitz player then you'll feel
like with the increment you'll be okay
so I don't think you you worry about
that you just play you take black and
you go now we're gonna see her heart
that is any Hwang's is gonna be in this
next game will she be able to play with
a hundred percent focus after having the
championship in her here
in the classical portion and then losing
in the last round that having in our
hand again in the rapid portion and
losing it again can she's still
maintaining and now she's got to feel
like she's getting life after life after
life being able to win this game so it's
incredible
these two are showing that either one
will be an absolutely deserving champion
whatever happens next the creative
American chess is about to be hollow
this is an incredibly well played
playoffs you know we've called some
playoffs for the Women's Championship
but this one it's funny is not only fun
there's a great chest doing wonderful
games with the way pieces and I do I do
agree with Maurice that black is the
superior pick in general with the
second-in-command that's just you you
try it out enough moves and suddenly
it's gonna be six and a half minutes to
five and a half minutes Jennifer call it
for us who wins I'm gonna go with naazy
I think she's a she's it's very very
close but I'm gonna go with nause
Maurice call it for us who wins for a
man who loves to share is opinions look
at this tall crazy people just punching
at each other never know who's gonna win
when that happens it's only who knows
there's somebody's Atlanta haymaker you
know this is just look at them they're
our fighters
it's incredible I'm so impressed by the
two of them they're showing their stuff
yeah but I'm gonna go with Annie all
right I think she's gonna hold your own
with ice water in her veins and I'm
gonna split that I'm gonna go with
Jennifer we're together neither these
women can be a bad and we're on the edge
of our seats we're gonna be back in just
a few minutes for this dramatic playoff
here at the Women's Chess Champion
fantastic fantastic
[Music]
health care in America is changing
evolving and we are helping lead the
transformation ascension is made up of
physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
healthcare innovators nationwide
ascensions faith-based heritage means we
have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
two billion dollars in care for people
living in poverty and for programs to
help them whether it's in a hospital a
neighborhood clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
Ascension be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of the 2018
US Women's Test Championship we are down
to Armageddon battle between 9250 and
Annie Wang
whoever wins she will be one heck of a
deserving champion what phenomenal chess
we've seen here in this playoff I know
it's so exciting one one in the rapids
and any has drawn black for the
Armageddon and that gives her to all
odds naazy because he has the white
pieces
she must win but both players have won
with white so far in the playoff too
close to call yeah this is gonna be five
minutes to four minutes with just a two
second degree by the way to kiss second
increment is hard to accumulate because
even if you play really fast it takes
you about a second to make the move
exactly the physical the act of
physically moving the pieces does take
time it does I mean though if you have
the edge you'll win the game if you have
like a queen mate situation right and
you'll be able to do that because you
just keep getting the two extra seconds
exactly that's the key thing you can't
flag somebody in a rook verse right
three musicians laughable any at the
board she has had such a calm demeanor
as has her opponent Nagi
she's been regal throughout as well
what's great about this too is that
these two because of this matchup we
will be talking about them as rivals now
for the future years absolutely we'll
remember this match between the two so
you can just see us doing commentary
next year when the two play each other
again and the year after that they're so
young
especially if Annie decides to stay in
chess over the next several years we'll
be talking about them fighting it out
and especially if Annie keeps playing
like she's playing she's gonna be
fighting for the title we won't be
looking at her as an underdog anymore
nobody's gonna overlook this young lady
as Jennifer you will be as up there as
well but she's gonna be one of the
pre-tournament favourites
if she keeps playing like this in the
ensuing year before the next
championship that's right anyway and
Jennifer you are gonna be towards the
top of the table in future years no
doubt and probably some other girls that
are being inspired by Annie Wang right
now saying you know what this could be
me I need to study I need to work on my
game more
I'm being inspired why did you say yes
agreed she's got ice water I want some
of that whatever she's drinking just
incredible
but of course nausea Mackenzie a
tremendous champion has been here and
the lady I picked that they're both
showing remember that any weighing lost
or final game after a phenomenal
tournament she lost how disappointing
and she went down badly then she came
back to play a gorgeous game it's when
the first game of the playoffs Naz ena
with her back against the wall the exact
same thing right there just showing so
much mental fortitude in the face of
adversity our fighters it's incredible
nausea is also a fitness freak Naz he's
always in the gym every day working out
keeping herself in top top shape she's
used to going the extra mile she's got
that determination she's got that
stamina she could probably play another
five rounds and it'd be no problem you
wanna play tomorrow she'll be in it but
now they're all down to one game look at
them they're blitzing out basically the
same position they just had what works
out for her last time the Kings Indian
attack what did what did Annie get in
her head that she should have done I
wonder if she may have chatted with her
coach beforehand and her coach told her
you should have played this move in that
setup wonder if she's found that out as
they're in the exact same position
blitzing up a moment believe she did she
must know what she should have done and
I think that certainly Naz ease playing
the same way and we're in the exact same
position she just lost in no doubt she
has talked to her coach there's no
question as she's played to this
position she should not play the reap
[ __ ] white should not repeat the h5 but
a night eight G's and she did not yes
and put the night on g4 after g5 you
take or g5 you could even play h5 and
then Knight g4 and that pawn on h6 is
always the Achilles heel in the position
people talk to their coach about the
game yeah
she has played g5 ooh this move Knight
h2 was directed against that move g5 but
that move is no oh you're expecting h5
followed by Knight g4 keeping that pawn
on h6 as a perpetual long-term target
and you were showing the Bobby Fischer
sacrifice with Knight takes g5 and
Bishop f4 when black tries for that fi
break right that is and she laid the
light move h5 this is what she wanted in
the previous game that she didn't get
remember that night on h2 got stuck
there defending pawns on f3 and g4 now
the night on g4 that will actually be
defending the e5 pawn double duty and
rook F a we've seen this with Knight g4
Oh are we gonna see that Bobby Fischer
sacrifice on h6 and g5 King b8 first
king be a first even setting up even
more so that idea of the bishop ending
on f4 after the sacrifice so but
anything there's no Queen e6 check
anymore in that's right so that a3 and
the idea is if you go
f5 Bishop d2 by the way was played you
go f5 which is like you jump on the e5
square Maurice yes you'll um pass on and
then you jump on the e5 square because 6
g 6 is going to be that's right work so
nice on the board and I'm expecting
knight on f3 to e5 the other night
pardon me went to e5 now in the night of
96
exactly no the rook can move but what's
happened here
but there are six races he's doing she's
playing it so well much much different
than the first game which was a little
bit double-edged at a moment there I
mean was that one minute lead on the
clock is nasi look at this idea
yes I'm gonna be freaking out Bishop d6
I don't know Bishop I don't think she's
gonna play but it's a and allowing night
and then II five and just on a straight
exchange Wow
thou be insane that would be insane
she's playing he's play me for what what
what g4 doesn't work Knight takes c6
check and then the other night in and
that's money that's huge and there's a
trade on g2 boy they're playing quickly
but now now but White has everything
simply everything because there's gonna
be a Bishop f4 landing shortly as well
okay we gotta get back to the to the 2d
board can she take on h5 she's gonna
drop g4 than e6 big big trouble really
bad really bad this has been a
strategical mastery by suspicious though
no [ __ ] she played the right way she
played the way you're supposed to play
exploiting this move f5 which was
premature yes I think that's really the
story the v break in this position was
not quite right she might have been told
she should have played at five do it in
that setting yeah so now she's about
naazy to just implement the correct way
to play in this position and now the
time is ticking down dramatically and
she's looking for rules give me credit
here I mean obvious but it's a blitz
game absolutely so easy to trip up and
she's also played them so quickly yep
such a practical player is not a big
easy look at this this is the first time
anyway and we've seen her and a massive
time that we do have the move rook e8
because she has no plan rikiei played
and here I'm just looking at night g6
that just makes so least drawing me so
strong and again not only that but h6 is
hanging
bishop is coming to f4 you know
Brook h74 trying but now there's a pin
along the e line Queenie sex because I'm
gonna go Bishop f4 check you know we
want to play anyway we're anywhere yeah
going down with black she's taking on
aged five but that's not gonna help one
bit because there's got to be Queen e5
crying Oh Queen kicks off a straight
wins on the spot I just wish the knife I
know react Oh No if she plays that it's
gonna be all she missed it
Queen takes on g4 she missed that check
she don't got an overwhelming position
exactly what she missed that I mean this
is completely crushing but she didn't
miss that move right and she's gonna
have to win the game again but she's
threatening the night and then I can't
go to have six because after a check
then the take on e7 and the Queen f4
check and the deer no moves east seven
Bishop which protects the night is about
to be captured and there goes Annie's
night after 1967
King a I lost queen of six doesn't it
yes it does yes it's right now Queen f6
Kobe's Anna I think she spotted it -
Queen I think your intention had been to
take on e7 without thought right but you
could just say gonna have six and that's
even stronger much more power that would
be a way to close this out that fine
Queen f6 and that there are no moves
yeah you're losing gonna play it there
it is no seven also winning also totally
winning
she's she's capturing the knight on f6
neck right because if you take on e7
just Queen f6 and that's a straight
piece with as I know the ESM the e1
rookies just defended with background
problems to boot and there we have Rick
f77 no Knight d5 the same back ranked
problem for for black but you spoke
about yep Maurice with Queen takes f6
Knight d5 naazy by kids E now for the
bodies all night if I win guys
sure anything no but she's fine Knight
d5 I think yes I think she's gonna find
Knight d5 she's a player
I think she's gonna play the most inside
that is winning totally winning
I mean all the problems and looking at
Knight d6 with all kind of four
possibilities yeah 20 seconds left she's
got we're gonna see her again her title
back
mazi but kids he had trade on a one-up a
full-piece rook to f8 getting out of the
fork yeah but eight-six is hanging also
yes rookie 7 is possible as well there's
so many ways to win this position this
is over the place itself alright Queen
d6 also looks really really good it's
just a picking right now yeah so little
choices yeah it was an amazing run for
Annie but she could not finally beat
this past champion rook to e7 on the
board a mid minute and 57 seconds only
15 seconds left
time ticking down she's not gonna be
able to piece down clock down everything
no Karen to play Queen c6
has been played there's a rook mercy 17
yep followed by 703 we know the
diagonals and the right know how you
even move after 187 kick the Queen off
the diagonal rookie 7 Queen sees like 9
h5 but that shouldn't trade every mind
in that case rook c7 to evacuate this
Queen from the diagonal to set up Queen
f3 check yeah she's just calculating
that move or anything else Queen takes
h6 also wins and she's played it she
grabbed the pond and what to do there
just just know anything defending and
now she can just pile up on the night
and go into the straight into the
endgame Bishop g5 g5 is another simple
way to pull that off exactly Queen g7
looks good
oh boy Jay that also looks
get out the blade five immediately and
then check and shocking shocking by
exactly all of it now is crushing and
she is everything and she's played rook
to f7 another win forcing the exchange
of Queens and he flats like Nagi because
he is our 2018 u.s. women's nano Ken
should be standing right yes should be
here there is the clock is done Naz he
has done it once again from 2016 now not
having the title last year but just a
tremendous fighter and as pulled it off
she's the 2018 champion amazing struggle
anyway we'll have no shame in her game
for that amazing that she put up as well
but it was not to be the Cinderella run
and short as an Aussie by kids he pulls
it off he once again fantastic and what
a wonderful a couple of games there by
Mazzy because the after losing the first
one he with the black pieces wow talk
about your comeback that is just so
extraordinary and there she is our new
US Women's Champion the queen of
American chess national master Nagi
because he hails from Las Vegas 2018
u.s. women's chess champion she takes
home $25,000 the spot on the women's on
the big team and her second women's
championship title absolutely fantastic
and let's look at how all the women
finished boy any weighing of course a
sensational performance we won't soon
forget
she finished with eight points but she
did not get through nagi in the tiebreak
clear second for Annie
Irene a crush in clear third and then we
had a tie between Jennifer you also got
her final WH and norm here I don't
really dance to Jennifer absolutely
and our favorite confessor and as
economy always a contender here passive
Abraham Yan Onan even scores sabina
Poyser our defending champion did make
her mark and put her mark on this
tournament change the destiny completely
paving the way for an aussie for kids
these victory by beating annie in the
last round absolutely and meanwhile we
also have a cute accordion Maggie
Fang youngsters the local an asura [ __ ]
we're stuck on goalie tianni who didn't
have a nice couple wins in her final
stretch and a Rio card dorsa Derek Shani
inspiring to many but not her tournament
right her rookie year but she came she
came well I mean she had some of the
positions just a poor result and we went
on the open division yes Sam Shanklin
Wow stunning
Eden house for him look at that Fabiano
carolina just half a point behind Sam
but a point and a half ahead of Wesley
so these two men Fabiano and Sam just
dominated the competition and as Fabiano
actually tweeted he didn't think that +5
wasn't going to be enough here exactly
Sam Wesley so in clear third by a full
point over and a Kimora Lenderman and
Robson who all got five and a half not
bad for Alex and Ray but certainly a
result that naka would like to forget
soon
Geoffrey zhong with five points viata
zoria such a memorable event for the odd
and including those two wins among
players in the big three our smooster
date narrows our group at four and a
half the erosion of Colby on such a
wonderful start but faltered in the end
they have a poor finish a wonder Leo I'm
nothing to be ashamed of with this four
and a half out of eleven he played some
great chests including drawing all three
members of the big three and then also
winning his first game of the US
Championship history a wonderful outing
for the young rookie but here he is the
man everybody's talking about one of the
great chess stories of 2018 actually
grandmasters ssamjang
and hard work is character and his work
ethic and his amazing preparation please
seem ahead of the big three and gave him
a $50,000 first prize for twenty seven
hundred plus ratings just such a story
and the Olympic spot as well a great
performance for Sam our congratulations
to both winners but you know it's not
just the players that make this
tournament everything they are it's also
the people behind the scenes
absolutely well you know the show that
we brought to yourselves who were
watching there's a big big group of
people supporting me yeah and just to
name some of them from spectrum studios
and silverback we have Randy sing feel
the director of the spectrum studios we
have Jen we have Kevin we have Eric John
yes we've got Tammy and keep a Bryan
Bryan and Marcus absolutely just a
Justin yes I'm filling in for Kevin now
such a wonderful team of course at the
Chess Club Tony and joy who actually
been here for all 10 years of this and
of course I'll shout out to our
colleagues Christine Christian Charla
who's brought as the count corner as
well as Alejandra Ramirez and Yvette
Garcia for the Spanish broadcast right
exactly and across the street at King
side Robert Haas and Eric Hanson chess
bra but we have the woman of the hour
our new US Women's Champion naazy
Piketty well she was down a full point
in this tournament with two rounds to go
and what a comeback by Nazified kids e a
champion in 2016 did not defend her
title in 2017 but shoulder she's made of
not only coming back once but also
coming back in the Armageddon taking it
all the way to the Armageddon she is now
your 2018 US has champion now see how
does that sound amazing
I still cannot believe that I won
especially the way well I didn't even
think just couple days ago that I would
be playing tiebreak so of course I was
very happy yesterday that that was a
possibility but I started so badly today
I just realized that I was more nervous
than I thought I was that's why in the
first game I just didn't see anything
and that really stung me off and it was
very hard to come back and forget the
first game so I'm so happy I pulled it
off
tell us when you were a point down in
the tournament itself the tournament
side did you think that you had any
chance of even getting into a tirade um
I did but not a big chance of course I
mean she had the best I mean not the
best but the strongest players left at
the end of the tournament so I had my
hopes but she played so well and she'd
be the Irina and I didn't get a chance
to even fight with her it was a quick
draw towards the end honestly I thought
my chances were like 5% not more you
know how did you feel about herself is
the way she's handled herself in these
championships as a 15 year old she's
amazing she made this tournament so
exciting and she's only 15 it's crazy
when I was her age I couldn't contain
myself like she does and she's such a
good player and good defender and she
was very tough that second game you had
to come back after losing that first
game I mean she just wiped you out that
first game it's hard to imagine many
people bouncing back from that one and
yet you still remain composed and were
able to come up with a very nice victory
yes so I quickly meta dated like for two
minutes and I got a good advice that she
plays really fast and don't try to play
as fast as hard because then I guess
she's just better at blitz than I am cuz
I I I play better when I think so I took
my time in the second game and only
speed it up at the end when I was
already much better and I think that
helped a lot that last game though the
Blitz game itself you seem to just know
exactly what to do he just started
dropping moves and ice on e5 and then
trading off in the other Knight to e5
you must have felt good once you got
that positional advantage so be honest
that was not evaluate in the position I
was just playing on her time because I
can't make a draw and all the advantage
I have is the one minute on the clock so
I thought I would play faster than she
did and
just really presser on time because even
if I get slightly worse position it's
not easy at all to win when you have a
few seconds on the clock
so that was my plan to play on her time
but in the game I actually got a very
good position and and a winning endgame
we mentioned that for her she's a
teenager she'll be able to go back and
do homework and and all that but for you
this is your career what does it mean
for you to be the US Women's Champion
this year
hey means so much that I could win this
again I mean to be honest this is my
first time here and the worst result I
had was the second place so I can't
complain but of course to win this is I
come here to win so garlic cute all the
hard work in preparation what about your
family
looking on they must be thrilled right
now right now but I'm sure he's still
watching and my family's probably up in
Moscow and watching as well I think
there are more nervous than I was at
least I thought so until I started
playing today yeah we're all very happy
well congratulations a magnificent
performance great comeback you are now
the 2018 u.s. women's chess champion
well-earned and well earned well
deserved and thank you for making our
show so entertaining indeed and we of
course in seat what's the capital of
chess in the United States we have a lot
more chests coming up yes we do some
hurt that's classic we're just going to
go down from may 15 to the 23rd and you
can catch that live on us chess champs
calm and of course also stay up-to-date
with all these broadcasts on the st.
Louis Chess Club YouTube channel and for
us we have the grand chest tour coming
up and that's going to be in Leuven in
Paris from June 12th to June 24th go to
Grantchester org for more
information there's also what junior
clothes and us junior women's clothes
later in the summer so always so much
chest here in st. Louis and I encourage
you to plan a trip see it for yourself
guys we've had lots of advances tour
finally st. Louis Rapids the sink
they'll pop and the London classic to
round out the grand grand Chester tour
and that's right stay tuned for more
information on that we're definitely
gonna be covering it in some way no
doubt we have Fabiano Carolina st.
Louis's own is going to be facing magnus
carlsen in that's right and maurice any
final thoughts on this epic event Wow is
it more games commentary this was so
exciting one of the most thrilling
championships remember we've seen the
favorites win in previous years on one
side or the other and last year and the
year before Fabiana Caruana won in 2016
Wesley still won in 2017 to have two of
the players in this tournament who
weren't that one of the very very top ok
na z 1 on the lady side but we've we
haven't seen arena 1 now in three tries
we haven't seen others at on ski win in
three tries a turning of the tide Sam of
course a fantastic results just
incredible to believe that he got eight
and a half in this field out of 11
points and Fabiano Carwin also with the
spectacular results so there we just saw
something amazing and amazing still
anyway she will be back tremendous
attempt on her part it was not to be but
still a great player American chess is
in great hands this is what the u.s.
championships is all about and certainly
an exciting event guys I want to thank
everyone and it's great to be with the
Superfriends you guys are amazing to
work with it's so much fun I can't wait
to do it again
Thank You Maurice and absolutely
likewise burrows yes with the analysis
in the background there go take a look
at that game over there looks very
exciting
exactly Kylee and Rebekah and bath and
Brian Chester all this
food has been wonderful fortunately they
keep us anchored in this cookies boy
gets mad and of course to everybody
watching all from over 100 countries
it's just wonderful to get that
perspective on how this chess is a
global game yes and even though it's the
u.s. Chess Championship it has so many
stories and players from so many
different backgrounds the fact that
we're attracting a global audience is so
many older absolutely so we are going to
be hosting a closing ceremony soon so
you'll get more information and photos
from that on us chess camps calm until
then I'm Jennifer Shahaji signing off
for Yasir Sara Juan Maurice Ashley and
everybody at spectrum studios and silver
back at the st. Louis chess club thank
you all for joining us good night
[Music]